there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
sounds like a plane's going to come down
and hit us maybe some were sitting here
streaming and a damn jet plane comes
down and hits the [ __ ] house i i
gonna be just like johnny darko a jet
engine like crashes through yeah
everything [ __ ] vanished and then the
[ __ ] camera is sitting on the side
you see my dead ass [ __ ] laying over
there like that
pecker hanging out should be [ __ ] fun
be a funny way to die live streaming
that [ __ ]
yeah sad to be laughing not funny for
you but funny for everyone watching i
guess sandra would be like that's not as
big as i thought it was going to be
like
i needed sandra today
i did [ __ ] for the sasquatch show i
had to shave my back jenny's like i
don't want to shave your back i had to
fight over to [ __ ] get she finally
shaved my back we didn't fight over it i
was just kind of like really i said i
need a german girl up here to shave my
back
i'm gonna fly it fly i'm gonna fly all
300 pounds of sandra down here so she
could shave my [ __ ] back
my german back shaver see here's another
thing now she gonna put that in her name
oh my god yeah that's good
i was b i was i was florida skunk ate
this morning you were well that's the
thing like i didn't really notice like
for the past few days but i guess
because of the testosterone that you're
taking
yeah um i never had back hair
yeah it was uh it was [ __ ] wolf man
yeah it was something else like i said
it must have happened like fairly
recently because this is so gross like
way to start this [ __ ] [ __ ]
but like and like i said he's like he's
he's want me to shave it off and i'm
just like oh jesus christ okay
um this is my life now
and um
and then i told him like when i had done
half of it i was like oh [ __ ] you should
have left it on because we're doing the
bigfoot show it's like that would have
been super funny look this morning i was
[ __ ] walking walking to go take a
shower and walking next to the mirror
and looked at myself you know like i do
look at myself in the mirror look like
that i saw something look like a damn
shadow behind me and i was like what
what the [ __ ]
i had hair growing in the back of my
[ __ ]
shoulders
yeah backs all the way down man
and i was like
[Laughter]
i started getting again i'm shaving kits
and [ __ ] i said look at that [ __ ]
and you didn't notice it before you're
like god damn
is that it must have happened fairly
recently because i didn't notice that
trt
[Laughter]
looking like a damn
[ __ ] wolf man we had to get the
clippers yeah first because the the
razor wasn't caught in it yeah no like
literally wasn't cutting it yeah i was
like i couldn't believe that came off my
back i couldn't believe it either it was
like enough to make a cotton ball you
could make another like little bitty top
yeah well that's what i that's what i
sometimes say that's what i say to
pookie when i'm doing her grooming with
her little glove and everything and all
the hair i pull it out and she looks at
it and smells it i was like look i can
make a tiny little pookie yeah out of
this and she's just like can i eat it i
was like please don't eat that damn but
yeah so yeah so much hair
it's really funny because what you were
saying about getting hit by a plane
and dying with your pecker hanging out
and all that other kind of stuff i was
just thinking right like a minute before
we started this show i was thinking
please tell me that there is a sasquatch
starring porn parody called big dick
yeah i couldn't i mean there has to be
right i mean if i thought of that
sketchcock
that order yeah that works too that
works too yeah um so please tell me
there is one actually
that would be gabe well that's porn
lumberjacks up in canada
getting [ __ ] raided and molested and
raped
by a sas [ __ ]
it's kind of like a
wookie got a big old dick on it you know
what now that i'm now that i'm thinking
about it this is probably not just one
movie it's probably like a whole sub
genre yeah because like i said a lot of
like women's erotica like written
erotica is not sasquatch um primarily
but it's kind of like animal human
hybrids yeah like that's kind of like a
really big step genre donald bob says
said tom liked sandra so much he bought
the company
[Laughter]
that's funny sandra goes all men have
hair everywhere except on their heads
that's a good one but the thing is that
no this was
not normal [ __ ] um yeah it was
definitely not orange yeah it was just
like it was like the hair that you would
have on your legs
all of a sudden just starts [ __ ]
sprouting on your back it was thick and
it was like only in like a couple of
days
yeah cause like i said i didn't notice
it i didn't just happen what the [ __ ]
yeah it was like never had that yikes
and it was black yeah you're not talking
about you know [ __ ] old man white
hair
there's a new growth that's that's that
[ __ ] hormone therapy he's slowly
turning into a sasquatch
or a werewolf
or a werewolf or something werewolf
would be cooler i think
although more like a werewolf
yeah probably i kind of you get you give
me more of like times you see how i am
yeah you give me more of a werewolf vibe
than a sasquatch vibe because i do kind
of now okay now the thing about bigfoot
though or sasquatch if you prefer is
that
of all the sightings of him i kind of
feel like
you know
things like opinions differ about
whether he's kind of just like a chill
kind of peace-loving creature who's just
like hanging out or if he's like super
aggressive
yeah um
i don't know i kind of feel like most
people are just kind of like yeah he's
just walking around being cool or
whatever but i think there have been
like some reports where he like killed
people
that's that's a hippie version of
[ __ ] sasquatch oh look there's some
money
oh thank you dom
hi simon jenny looking forward to this
evening last two weeks of film
retrospectives were really good thank
you very much yeah we did some great
movies this past we did house this
morning if you haven't seen it from
1986.
um but yeah trying to keep this show
fresh we've been doing it for years man
yeah we started this back what uh five
years ago right more than five years ago
i think we started in summer like july
2016 something like that yeah so yeah
we've been doing it through but and this
the shitty thing well it's not shitty i
was like the scary thing is that as long
as we've been doing this show we haven't
been doing movie reviews the whole time
because like i said we've added more
[ __ ] like as time went on
but as many movies as we've done there's
still like a zillion that i want to do
and i haven't gotten to yet yeah so it's
a little alarming yeah now today we're
gonna uh knock we're gonna knock the
bigfoot the sasquatch show out uh we're
trying to get it we're gonna try to get
it done within a couple of hours or so
because uh
really we're being invited to go up to
the [ __ ] club for it's friday the
13th and it's a friend of ours birthday
so
yeah we'll do it we're not gonna let
this run four or five hours i mean we'll
see how it goes but i'm gonna try not to
drink too much because
like i said last time we went out last
time last friday after the show
and i think i only had two drinks on the
show and then i got to the bar and then
i had maybe two more but then i guess i
hadn't eaten all that much and it was
big tom who owns the club it was his
birthday they were having a surprise
party so they brought around cake and i
could only eat like one or two pieces of
cake and i'm like yeah i think i'm gonna
barf now yeah so so we left like before
midnight i think
i was uh last uh yesterday went down uh
went downtown safford ran into big tom
and his [ __ ] gag and just uh fell in
with them
and um
strange things are afoot at [ __ ]
downtown sanford those [ __ ] are
taking over the goddamn town i didn't
know it um
i hear i hear big tom talk and i'm like
yeah yeah okay he's he's building
another bar there another club and it's
very high-end he's having columns made
yeah yeah i already did a poster for it
yeah it's on the main strip and
everything and um that thing's going to
be a hit and then they took me down to
the civic center to show me
that theater
it's bigger than it's bigger than
firestone and more decked out than
firestone and they don't want much for
it for a night so we're gonna start
running events out of there i'd like to
do something like absolution there
maybe get sherry mouse and you in there
yeah and get those beds in there and
hook everybody up with tom
yeah and try to make a hundred thousand
that night then we divide it up i mean
absolution in case you don't know how it
happens every year uh well they didn't
do it last year obviously but it happens
every year in tampa and it's like a big
three-day
uh goth death rock
sort of synth wave type of uh festival
so it's live bands djs all that kind of
stuff i was uh
i'm getting sick of sitting around here
just living off my [ __ ] retirement
money man i need some money
yeah i was we watched that series
cocaine cowboys they said tom watch
cocaine cowboys that she was awesome
we're gonna have to talk we'll do a
matinee on it on sunday yeah we'll take
water to south florida we'll talk about
that because that was actually really
entertaining it was a good it was i
recommend it and i was you know looking
at how much money those guys were making
and i was like man i need to make some
money
no right it's like every time i watch
stuff about drug dealers i'm like
yeah
you know
you don't have to you don't have to deal
drugs to make that kind of money well
yeah you have to do drugs to make that
kind of money yeah but i would i would
be happy with a fraction of that just
doing it legally well yeah and you're
not looking over your shoulder all the
time yeah because that would kind of
blow yeah and then you don't have to lie
about where all this money's coming from
yeah there was because there was a lot
of those shenanigans going around going
on in that uh in that show and me and
big tom we're talking about it we're
convinced that we can make that not that
kind of but we can make a lot of money
just with just with the just with the
tout with the
the pool of talent that we know
and that the money that him and his
his gang or i call him a gag that's a
gang of businessman
scots the other one yeah and then
there's i've met the other two guys and
they were cool too the other one was
like a spitting image of [ __ ] harvey
keitel out of saturn 3.
yeah he's from argentina though and he
likes motorcycles so we were getting
down talking about custom bikes and [ __ ]
he was looking tomorrow yeah
like you're not cute because now i'm not
kidding do we need a cuban in this gang
something that because every gang has
something scary
[Laughter]
yeah not not quite so scary right yeah
uh somebody's already said uh danny
rolling ghostface said i've seen a
squatch before
it wasn't that big height wise and it
resembled a cyan ape from the cartoon
dragon ball z minus the tail and had
hairless pointy ears like a bat and a
snout like alf
[Laughter]
and golf ball size glowing red eyes like
a neon sign and they just disappeared i
kind of feel like
a lot of people have said that they have
glowing eyes right
which
if it was a real animal and i'm not okay
the thing is is what he's describing
also a [ __ ] a wild pig kind of looks
like that well and i kind of feel like
maybe some of it because we'll get into
this a little bit too because i'm we're
going to talk about bigfoot sasquatch
mainly which you know like i said that's
they're kind of their main territory if
you want to call it that it's mostly
like the pacific northwest like parts of
canada [ __ ] like that uh there have been
other sightings elsewhere but those are
like the most common ones however uh
there is also a large contingent of
sightings down in florida although they
call that the skunk ape yeah although
it's pretty much the same thing um what
you're talking about yeah i i don't buy
it though it's a big hairy hominid that
lives up to me although i will say from
a scientific standpoint and i'm not you
know taking a stand one side of the
other i think it's unlikely uh that they
exist but if they do
i kind of feel like maybe it's more
likely
that they would exist somewhere like
florida because the
climate is more conducive i guess well
and also it's you know i i feel like we
had you know there was like um i don't
remember how many years ago this was but
there was like some monkeys like this
zoo either burned down or flooded or
some [ __ ] like that and a bunch of the
monkeys like escaped yeah and there was
like a humongous like a troop of them
and they lived in the woods like in
florida like for a very long time so
when animals even if they're not
indigenous to this area when they escape
into the wild from a zoo or from
somebody's like pet collection or
whatever um just like we have a big
problem with like boa constrictors and
stuff because a lot of people keep them
as pets and if they escape um we have
like they're kind of an invasive species
because
florida's climate is really conducive to
it's a rain forest animals yeah like
just [ __ ] going nuts and you produce
it like crazy pretty much pretty much
wolves bears uh big cats can live here
any kind of snake any kind of fish can
live here
salt and fresh water we got it both
yeah but the thing is is that we're
already getting on the subject i guess
the thing is when it comes to the
florida skunk ape
chances are you're talking about a hoax
but let's say somebody did see something
and thought it was the skunk ape
statistically most likely but he's
misidentifying a bear
well i kind of feel like they think that
i mean most people that kind of look
into this kind of thing
they said most of the time 99 of the
time they're sure that even when people
see
uh or supposedly see bigfoot like up in
the pacific northwest what they're
probably seeing is a black bear yeah
like walking there bear can walk on its
hind legs but if it's front egg front
legs are injured can walk on their back
legs like a damn man they got it on
video and they can do it for extended
periods of time
they had a bear who broke both of its
front
legs and walks around on his back legs
permanently just when he stops he gets
down yeah but he'll just walk on his
back legs like a man
it's weird looking but i've seen the
footage of him
well
if you catch a glimpse of a bear walking
on its high lane for some reason you
know and it's kind of an obstructed view
through the trees
and you got
you got skunk ape in your mind
you might think that you saw a skunk ape
yeah it's a bear because we've seen some
big i mean even in florida like and they
probably they have bigger bears i think
up in the pacific northwest um we i mean
even here in florida we have black bears
and i've seen some pretty big ones just
wandering around people like our
neighborhood i've seen a really big one
sitting in our [ __ ] way and what's
funny is their posture and their
mannerisms are very humanoid
it's like it's like an ape an ape or a
human
i mean
we were coming up the driveway and one
of them was sitting there on it's on its
ass with your legs out with its arms
down outside just like a person yeah and
saw it by her little garage and he
rolled over
and got up and walked away but he was
sitting there on his ass like a person
with his hands down by his side feet out
in front of him
yeah so i was going he's like oh [ __ ]
i got him moved yeah and not scared at
all
and he was bigger than a man
yeah much bigger that if he stood up
he'd be
six and a half feet probably maybe
bigger maybe bigger because i yeah i
mean i've seen big bigger ones like that
around here like i said even just
running around our neighborhood i
haven't seen one in a while because they
shot a bunch of them yeah because
somebody got
attacked sort of
um i think the last time we saw one and
i think we mentioned this before was we
saw one just in the middle of the day
kind of crossing the street thank you
victor i need to go get some food go
ahead and play a 30 minute commercial
but yeah so we saw one just in the
middle of the day we were coming back
from you know the grocery store or
something and he was just walking up the
driveway of a house because the garage
was open and it was walking just walking
into the garage i guess maybe they had a
fridge in there and it was kind of like
hey it was going for the i'm gonna see
if they got anything good in the fridge
because it was taken out for a
refrigerator
and we saw him go in there so we said
maybe we should go tell the people that
live there that there's a bear in their
garage so they don't walk in and like
scare it
they're far more intelligent than people
think they are they're not dog-like
they're more ape-like they can open
doors they can open a car door they can
open the refrigerator they remember
everything they'll go right into a house
and go right to the refrigerator of a
house they've never been in but they
know what a refrigerator is they'll open
it up yeah they're like hey there's
there's yummy things in here yeah
there'll be a security camera of them
sitting down on their asses in front of
the open door the refrigerator [ __ ]
hand of food to each other and [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] ridiculous it looks like apes
kind of and they're and they're happy
rolling around on their backs
that's great we found a [ __ ] fridge
give me that beer juice yeah pick up
jars
looks like they'll open the top of a jar
and just start pouring it in their
snouts
that's no good olives
they'll like that one yeah
it's like some it's like stuff you would
think that an ape would do
so
some of these sightings of bigfoot
are apes or these are bears
yeah i'm sure they are um some of them i
don't you know some of them and like i
said i'm not discounting because out of
all the quote unquote paranormal
stuff
um this one's is the most popular this
one i think is probably the most
plausible because is it plausible that
there are some undiscovered uh species
of hominid that's like wandering around
out in the pacific northwest somewhere
sure that's plausible i don't know how
likely it is but gorilla was paranormal
until somebody shot one and brought it
back to england right africans knew
about them for a long time
but white people had to see it to codify
it before it became a reality that [ __ ]
doesn't because nothing's real unless
white people say it is well it had to
end up in a british museum for that [ __ ]
to be real yeah well i think maybe the
same thing and maybe the same thing is
going on with bigfoot too because
um you know
legends about a bigfoot like creature a
sasquatch like creature have been around
for you know for like the native
americans for like a really really long
time
so
there's probably something to it it's
just i don't know
if it's still around or if it's you know
i got a good feel for the situation
having done a lot of time out in the
field with the us army and the infantry
and being a scout and being raised by my
dad who's a mississippi [ __ ] redneck
who just [ __ ] hunted constantly with
all that damn
he had hunting rights on a big old piece
of masonite corporation logging land and
my dad grew up doing this [ __ ]
and he was a bigfoot fan okay he wanted
he he wants a bigfoot to be real
but i could do his voice and everything
and come up with his explanations for
there's not enough habitat there's not
enough breeding population you know
it
if there was a bigfoot most likely would
be in washington state or canada
yeah well that's where most of the
sightings are like i said not all of
them there's kind of sightings
everywhere but that's what my dad said
and he said that back in the set he was
saying that back in the 80s because
there is a lot of wilderness up there
still like you can go thousands of miles
without really anything being there if
that exists it ain't here
ain't no way that could be here i'd have
seen it
i've seen everything yeah
well he was right though yeah he says
you can't walk two miles here and not
hit a road
i would have seen him cross the road
why did that there was just no you know
in the south
there is nowhere that's really secluded
except
florida everglades and certain parts of
the damn louisiana bayou
yeah i could see something like that
maybe surviving there but i don't know
it's kind of a large
i i kind of feel like the only way that
it could exist was if it was an
opportunist
um like a bear is
where it would kind of just eat anything
like that came across his path because
that's why i think bears are so
successful is because they'll just
they'll get out of garbage cans they'll
eat plants they'll eat berries they'll
eat whatever so they have to be
omnivores i feel like if it was a
predator
i just don't feel like it would because
there's too much other competition i was
arguing about it with my dad because i
was really good i was really wanting to
say now that something like that could
be out there
and he would go back to the same thing
that he would go on when it came to loch
ness monster there would have to be a
large enough breeding population and a
large enough breeding population
anywhere near
civilization would be noted because it
would make a mark in the ecology
yeah i mean
it would leave traces behind its eating
stuff it's leaving waste behind it's
[ __ ] and another thing is is that
something like a bigfoot probably would
not
shy away from being seen it would just
be out in the open
yeah that's kind of the thing about it
that gives me pause like i said i don't
think it's impossible
um but
in some ways i kind of think that we
would have had more evidence of it but a
lot more contact
you'd have people down at lake clarko
down at sequoia national for redwood
forest down in the sequoia national park
they'd be out at [ __ ] lake clark club
clark oh on those [ __ ] floating damn
[ __ ]
party barges i don't know what what do
you call that goddamn thing they'd be
out there on their [ __ ] inner tubes
and [ __ ]
and the family of sasquatch walked down
to the water and [ __ ] you know
looking at people
you know begging for food
look at yeah looking in the garbage can
and then they just walk you'd see that
regularly
yeah because i feel like it would be
like the same thing as like a black bear
same thing as a black bear or a gorilla
which i you know they don't really feel
the need to hide from anybody
like i said i've seen black bears just
trucking through our neighborhood right
like if they were a loch ness monster
their loch ness monsters there'd have to
be a breeding population so you talk
about 40 of them 20 to 40. and they'd be
taking sun on the bank laying over and
flip on their flippers and having
sunshine on their bellies and [ __ ]
like when walrus and stuff do
yeah walrus didn't hide
something that big well like i said you
wouldn't hide no and a something like a
sasquatch would be intelligent
and have arms and legs and it'd be
harmon it would be a hominid
and it would just see people is not a
threat because they'd be smaller and
weaker they'd walk right up to you
and punch you right in the face yeah you
got your first probably just take
something
you got food and they just going through
to see if you got any food mine now
buddy it'd be a bully
it wouldn't be it wouldn't that's that
doesn't fit for animal behavior
it wouldn't be some shy creature that
hides
it'd come down
and steal
yeah because it would just see you as a
subordinate creature
yes
you don't even have any fur you don't
have any fur you're too small
to be a threat so just come up and what
do you have and we just take it
because [ __ ] monkeys will do that
even little monkeys
they'll just jump on your head and be
like thank you they can't catch us
give me that purse and they're running
away run away with your damn purse to
see if there's any [ __ ] peanuts in it
and [ __ ]
roger dodger says the problem with
bigfoot is it's very blurry and you
can't get a good picture
yeah
uh maria says the best ecological
argument against sasquatch in the
pacific northwest is that there's not
enough food to sustain a breeding
population of a large primate i kind of
feel like that's
gonna be you know it seem in the way
that we talked about the loch ness
monster where it's just kind of like
there's not i mean for an animal that
size and particularly in the pacific
northwest there's a lot of other large
predators of that size that would be
competition well it could
she's partly right partly right
you're assuming though that the bigfoot
would be kind of like a gorilla that
you'd be trying to eat off bark and a
vegetarian organism but if it was more
like a bear
they could sustain themselves the same
way bear do which is by fishing
fishing and eating berries
but the thing is is that if they're
fishing to survive they'd be down there
with the bears [ __ ] competing for the
fish you'd see them that's what i'm
saying it's too much competition and
like i said you see bears all the time
yeah we're outside he bears all the time
out there they're not even scared of
standing there by the back [ __ ]
waiting for a [ __ ] fish to go by oh i
got him i got a guy
up on the bank
or come out with a mouth with his mouth
and something like a hominid is not
going to be something that's going to be
a real proficient fissure
you know that's not a fishing type body
no claws no big snout
that would be intelligent though you
know if you well they're making nets
well if they're making nets why aren't
they making other kind of technology
if that would lead an impact they'd be
making houses too
to be making all kinds of stuff if they
could make a net
yeah you know yeah you think it's like
because why would you want to just like
sleep outside if you were like smart
enough to make a net like you said at
least it's hard to filter that's right
you know that means you're talking about
human levels of intelligence which would
mean they're making houses they're
making fire
and they would show up
and even in the even even up in canada
you know we haven't really gone through
the [ __ ] stories yet some of this
stuff is
kind of messed sounds like man maybe
something like that did happen
the problem is in the modern era we have
[ __ ] spy satellites that can pick up
an individual human being just based
upon their thermal images
you can see it in a live time
it wouldn't surprise me if you know some
kind of if guys in the defense industry
have [ __ ] looked
and if they looked they wouldn't found
them they would have [ __ ] said
something
yeah i mean i was watching one of the
monster quest episodes
um you know about because like i said
there's a [ __ ] ton of monster quest
episodes about bigfoot because he's kind
of like the most popular cryptid and i
feel like
he kind of went through like a big
popularity in the 70s but now it seems
like um a resurgence like i see bigfoot
[ __ ] everywhere like the last few years
like there's movies about bigfoot
there's documentaries about bigfoot like
monster quest has like 50 bajillion
episodes about bigfoot and i watched
like three or four of them earlier
and then they're all kind of the same
but
it was kind of like a thing where one
guy was saying that he thought that
bigfoot existed but the reason that we
don't know about it is
and this is kind of comes up on a lot of
like ufo shows and stuff like that uh is
government cover-up and he's saying it's
there covering up his existence because
the logging industry
doesn't want
doesn't want a sasquatch to be there
because if he is there it's an
endangered species and then they
wouldn't be able to log in those forests
anymore so that was his yeah so i was
just but yeah like but they see they
want everything to be like a mystery and
a conspiracy and everything like that
which i get that like it's more fun like
that but yeah no way uh yeah i was just
laughing because victor said i still
think bigfoot is regular people most of
the time and then changes into bigfoot
like a werewolf
that would explain it uh thank you dumb
bomb jenny do you think the yeti from
himalayan folklore is related to bigfoot
i do kind of think because it seems like
a lot of different
cultures across the world
have
um these sort of legends about wild
hairy ape men that live in the forest
you know what i mean yeah well that
might be what you call a race memory
i kind of feel like maybe that's what it
is because it's just kind of like you
know how a lot of um you know how a lot
of cultures across the world have myths
about like dragons yeah um i'm not
saying that that's not coming from
like a kernel of truth somewhere
but
i do kind of feel like the reason that
so many cultures have
myths about these kind of
big ape men
is because like you said we kind of have
a cultural a shared cultural
memory
of things that were bigger than us yeah
well and you know and wild men yeah and
that's the thing it's like it's kind of
going back to our quote unquote caveman
ancestors too because like there were
all these other hominid species around
at the same time
that
you know maybe we have like you said
some kind of like race memory of it you
have
if you've ever done any time out in the
field
walking around in daytime and nighttime
you're in a small group of guys
it can get it's kind of like some [ __ ]
out of predator it is kind of
spooky in some ways if you think about
it well imagine
if this is a couple hundred years ago
and you didn't really know how big the
earth was
you didn't really know if there were any
lost continents
you're walking across in certain you're
walking across the earth
going into certain forests and as far as
you know no man has ever been there
before
there's this fear that you might run
into something that you've never seen
there's a lot of things that you might
worry about
what if it's a gigantic lion
that would be bad what if it's a big ass
lizard a dragon that would also be
better what if it's just a man that's
bigger than you and he's wild and crazy
just covered with hair like an animal
that's like something that would that
you could imagine that something like
that might exist yeah
and then later on
maybe you maybe you've heard about
monkeys and you've seen monkeys well how
big can a monkey get the monkeys that
maybe you saw
in 1500s down in some bazaar somewhere
was you know the size of a child well
maybe that's a baby how big does that
get does that get to be the size of a
man and are there other ones out there
that are much bigger than a man so just
kind of it's a normal
kind of like a normal process of
a normal part of your thought process is
that something like that might get
bigger
yeah than the things that you've seen
and then you could get big enough to
tear your face off be big enough to be
very dangerous
and that kind of looks like a man
are there other animals that look like a
man
maybe they are better than a man
you know so
it's kind of a reasonable thing to think
that way and most cultures have that
and
you know now
when when the english and in the
europeans i think dutch also heard heard
stories about a wild man
africans were talking about wild men out
in the forest covered in hair
educated europeans thought that was
[ __ ] ah no way they're talking about
the things that we were always [ __ ]
worried about a long time ago those
don't exist
it turns out it did exist they were
talking about a gorilla
which does kind of look like a person
yeah very man-like expressions and
everything it's very man-like half-half
man or mostly man
yeah more than half yeah i mean going by
dna
so when you see something like that that
reinforces a fear of maybe that there is
something that's even more man-like and
even bigger
and more bipedal
more of a threat because that exists
yeah therefore what
else might exist sure that's what
they're doing well and maybe that might
be why the bigfoot myth has kind of
gotten even more credibility lately
because like i said i i kind of feel
like for a long time
up until fairly relatively recently you
know it was kind of like yeah there were
you know there were neanderthals there
were this that and the other and then
but now then there were modern humans
but they've only recently discovered one
you know most humans have some
neanderthal dna in them like about two
percent and also that there was a bunch
of other competing hominids like in
other parts of you know like uh homo
what did they call the denisovans or
whatever um homo heidelbergensis they
had like all these different you know
the the little dwarfy ones
yeah the hobbit people and all this
other kind of stuff so the fact that we
used to think that it was a pretty clear
progression or succession i guess and
now we realize it was a lot more
complicated than that yeah that there
were actually a lot of different hominid
species that are sort of related but not
but sort of distantly related us and our
ancestors grew up in a world where they
were more than one kind of man
existing at one time and you had to
worry about them
because they were competing against each
other probably killing each other and
you're dealing with a world where most
people would be cannibals
lots and lots of evidence for
cannibalism meats meat if you you gotta
like get it where you can get it so
like today you have different races but
they can all interbreed they're the same
species back in the day they were
different species yeah kind of like the
difference between
a lion a tiger
a cheetah and a house cat and a bobcat
in the lakes they're all cats but
they're different species yeah
mankind was like that right so that was
a whole different playing field which i
think that blew some people's minds yeah
so
probably what happened is we kind of
have an inborn genetic
program in there that we evolved with to
have a fear that there are other kinds
of men
and maybe they're bigger and hairier and
stinkier yeah and better than you and
they can take our asses and eat us yeah
so you probably had to inherit
an instinctive caution for something
like that
that would have that would have been
that would have been good for your
survival which may be like i said
explains why pretty much every culture
across the globe has a similar
myth to this right they also have
similar myths about gigantic lizards
yeah they're probably not talking about
dinosaur they're probably talking about
giant [ __ ] alligators and crocodiles
moto dragons or something like that yeah
because you know what i mean monitor
lizards one of the things that you had
to compete for to live back in those
days was competing for water and every
one of those water holes had dam
alligators in it and if you couldn't or
crocodiles if you couldn't
negotiate the alligator threat you'd
[ __ ] die
but if you had kind of an inborn caution
or fear against giants you're like whoo
[ __ ] that you would take
care of not to be eaten by alligators
i'll get water later thanks yeah that's
dangerous water don't go over there
boom alligator get you yeah they're just
like little eyeballs popping yeah and
alligators get bigger probably got
bigger than they get today back in those
days
i would imagine in the medieval period
they describe [ __ ] gigantic gigantic
alligators because maybe they could live
to be two or three hundred years old but
that's horrifying that's right they had
enough
nobody said that's a dragon
it's ancient ancient ancients well you
would think that if that if you saw some
[ __ ] 30-foot [ __ ] crocodile
walking around and it's the same
alligator your great-granddad was
talking about yeah
exact same they're immortal they're
immortal right
how much gold has he amassed
that's what they're thinking it's like
smile getting there yeah
in his cave yeah victor makes a good
point he says
a while back they realized some tiny
shrew that hadn't been seen in a hundred
years i remember reading about this
wasn't extinct because they found its
poop they can find shrew poop in the
jungle of cuba but not bigfoot walking
around yeah and not bigfoot poop because
you think he'd make some big poops
bigfoot big poop that's enough
for big [ __ ] i guess you could call him
that too
oh i got like really behind
uh where was i okay
[Music]
uh nicholas says some of the best people
to talk to about sasquatch are the
natives up in british columbia it's just
a fact of life there now that's one
that's pretty much the only thing that
kind of gives me pause about it is that
it does seem like
the native americans did have kind of a
uh they were just kind of like they took
it as sort of like what was part of this
a foregone conclusion that these things
lived out there and then like when white
people came they were just like yeah
hello we've had these like for a really
long time
but you know i don't i don't know like i
said i'm not discounting it out of the
gate but they believe in thunderbirds
though too
well that's true they may be referring
to condor
yeah but condor hadn't been around a
long time just because it's in their
belief system doesn't mean that it
doesn't mean it exists i mean you know
it means that maybe something like that
existed a long time ago
yeah it could be yeah
um
you know they found
they found fossils of giant what's
called gigantopithecus which is a
gigantic australopithecus which
which some people have and
yeah we'll kind of get into that a
little bit near the end probably because
some people have said that maybe right
uh that's what they're talking about
when they talk about sasquatch even
though they've never been found in the
americas or like fossils of them and i
don't think it's ever been side by side
during human era
i don't think even i don't think any
humans live side by side with
gigantopithecus as far as far as i
remember
i'm not actually sure because some of
them i think there were still some of
them maybe that were still around when
that land bridge was there like in the
bering strait there's a chance that
maybe people found skeletons of this
that's yeah that's true too because
that's all you had to do back in the day
is find a skeleton of something you
couldn't really identify and [ __ ] it
was a dragon or a giant
i can't imagine like what ancient
peoples would have thought if they just
accidentally stumbled across a fossil of
like a [ __ ] dinosaur or something i
mean what the [ __ ] would you think well
the greeks thought that they were
griffins
and amazons
um they found a they had a place for a
bunch of dinosaur bones
they weren't real dinosaur bones they
were like from the period after the
dinosaur yeah were falling out of the
damn side of a hill and it was real and
they believed that
to be a battle site where a bunch of
amazons got killed by griffins and other
little gods that's a pretty good story
because they knew they couldn't
recognize they could not identify those
skulls
and then the skulls were big and they're
like well it's got a body like a line
and it's got a head kind of like an
eagle this is a griffin
so yeah it's legit look at the size of
this thing this is a gigantic woman it's
an amazon
yeah i mean if you didn't know what you
were looking at yeah
well they found they found they had a
they found a sarcophagus of a [ __ ]
giant cyclops
and then when they looked in there there
were bones of an elephant
so ancient greeks
saw an elephant skull and said look at
that big hole in the center that's a
cyclops
one eye and look how look at the size of
him they kind of had him arranged in
there like he was a man
yeah
you know because an elephant skull does
kind of look like a cyclops yeah i don't
really know what you're looking at
whether or not the guys that did it knew
it was an elephant and it was just used
it as a hoax
or if they actually misidentified it as
a cyclops nobody knows there's also a
chance that
the dudes that buried it the initial
dudes that buried it
bought that thing and they knew it was a
dead elephant
but once once it had been deflected they
passed it off as a cyclops could have
been
that's the thing i kind of feel like and
that's something i was thinking about
this because one of the monster quests
that i watched they were talking about
that uh that montauk creature that like
uh washed up they somebody found out on
a beach or something like that a few
years back and how everyone was saying
that that was like some unidentified
animal or something but i think it's
just because a lot of people aren't
really accustomed to seeing
um things that are rotten right well
yeah like rotten or skeletons it's and a
lot of times the skeleton
unless you know what you're looking at
doesn't necessarily look like the [ __ ]
with the flesh on it yeah you know
so
and then we also have to understand that
even back into the ancient era
greeks and romans and ancient persians
and [ __ ]
they hoaxed things
yeah and knowingly hoaxed things because
religion was a big money maker
back then
and uh mostly things and things
involving religions were hoaxed
statues that could move
early earlier
yeah robots uh they were using
megaphones to do like the voice of gods
from behind damn statues so that was
dead just talking and then lips probably
moved on it you know they were real good
at mechanics special effects special
effects and stuff like going to see
disneyland but people believed it but
not not the priests that were doing it
it was a hoax
well and you know there was a humongous
like market in [ __ ] uh you know fake
you know
foreskins and yeah toe bones of saint
this that and the other and enough wood
splinters to make a whole forest right
like yeah it was the true cross it's
like how could you you can prove that
yeah but it's just kind of like hey we
every church needs one so they could
like you know get the rubes to come
[ __ ] see it even the priest knew it
was a hoax yeah of course it was just a
way of getting people in there and
getting the people in there sure yeah
you know so let's go ahead and start
with the cases then
so yeah so most people i kind of feel
like most people in the world because
baby jesus skeleton
if it was a baby jesus skills and how
could there be a skill
because jesus rose it would have to be
in jesus he rose and transmuted into the
[ __ ] heavens
so that's why that's why the only thing
that's left of him is his foreskin
because
yeah yeah i can't believe i'm back soon
i can't believe that people back and it
was generally in the middle ages when
this happened but i can't believe that
people like thought about this much it's
like well we couldn't have like jesus's
body because he was supposed to be like
you know transported into heaven and
whatnot so it's like well oh but there
would be one piece of him left over
which would be his foreskin which was
removed when he was a baby you know as
you know with
you know according to jewish law so it's
like okay well cha-ching we can make was
let's go get some foreskins from
somewhere so it's like this little
[ __ ] dried up little piece of skin
and they just like put it in this big
fancy box and everything and everybody's
like ooh jesus is poor kid oh my god
nicholas came up with a good one
recordings of sasquatch chatter have
been vetted for authenticity and defined
as a language by a crypto linguist
cryptoligos
and they have tool use language and
burial traditions a crypto linguist
that's a new one
you might be talking about the sierra
sounds yeah which are kind of like
some sounds that you can hear them on
the internet
we're supposedly like sounds that are
brilliant there's a whole linguist
there's a whole
linguist involved in [ __ ]
cryptozoology
or or trying what is a crypto linguist
somebody trying to figure out a hidden
language
dead languages
we'll see no i think that's just a
linguist linguist yeah it's a linguist
linguist cryptolingus somebody's
bullshitting you bro
[Laughter]
portrait down says that's where onion
rings come from from jesus's foreskin
yeah sure but yeah so so like i said i
kind of feel like most people know i
mean other than the yeti which is all
white because obviously he lives in like
winter climbs
but bigfoot skunk ape everything like
that they usually kind of look the same
they look like kind of like a person but
kind of like a big upright ape um
anywhere from six to 15 feet tall uh
some of them are said to smell really
bad hence the name skunk ape they're
supposed to smell like skunky or like
rotten eggs or something although this
one this one monster quest i was
watching the guy said that he had seen a
sasquatch and it was a female because it
had big boobies on it but then he also
said that it smelled what did he say it
smelled sweet and musky so i guess he
thought that maybe she was like looking
for love type of thing like she was she
was in heat or something i think they're
getting that from the fact that gorillas
[ __ ] smell yeah yeah
people that work with them say yeah they
[ __ ] smell like bo
well they don't have deodorant they
don't have deodorant
[ __ ] gorilla right guard they don't
like the hair all over them and they're
under arms and [ __ ] they smell like bo
so
somehow the smell of
gorillas has gotten applied to
sasquatch
yeah well that's kind of what you could
think there were a sasquatch that's
probably what it would smell like so
like i said that's either i don't know
if that's even like um you know making
it more or less likely because if
something like that did exist yeah it
would probably smell exactly like
a big gorilla
[Laughter]
oh my god now like i mentioned earlier
we kind of brought this up earlier but
we were saying that like one very common
uh aspect of a lot of sasquatch
sightings is that they supposedly have
eye shine which is interesting because
obviously a lot of animals have eye
shine cats deer lots of other ones but
no primates
that are known have that
but a lot of people that said that
they've seen a sasquatch said that its
eyes glowed in the dark either
red or yellow or something like that and
that was how they first spotted that
yeah and it shouldn't they don't have
primates don't have that kind of eye i
mean yeah i'm just saying that's not
impossible i'm just saying that that i
mean yeah there are lots of other
animals that have eye shine yeah but no
primates do that that are known yeah
unlikely so
victor says teenage sasquatch smells
like axe body spray yeah yeah
if sasquatch is rumored to be sexy
like some people probably think sounds
good
shows up he's [ __ ] buffed out and
[ __ ] he's jacked you know he's jacked
and he's thinking
and he's got a [ __ ] hands on the face
he's got hair on him or or a [ __ ]
female
sasquatch [ __ ] shows up
and she's just [ __ ] all curves and
[ __ ] with big old [ __ ] boobs
i would imagine that that they they have
some [ __ ] erotic literature if i can
meet up like that like i said i'm sure
it's a whole subject yeah because but
that was never part of the lore
interestingly
which i kind of feel like maybe please
like i i don't want that in my google
history like you know sasquatch porn
but
now i'm kind of interested in how much
of it there i'm sure there's a lot
because like i said i know that there's
a lot of like werewolfy type of or like
shape changer type of porn there's a lot
of that
but stories are a product of the time
which is 1800s when their first late
1800s that's when they first started to
talk about this kind of stuff
they're kind of great hunter stories
something like teddy roosevelt would
talk about yeah i was at the campfire
and didn't he say he'd seen us
or knew a dude that said that someone
says or that killed somebody like broke
their neck no he was they set camp for
the night
and he um
and as
as they were around the campfire
somebody from out in the darkness threw
a [ __ ] stone
into the fire and it hurt near the
fireplace and people were it was out
there throwing stones at them and it
made kind of a kind of a wild man sound
and
they went out there to investigate and
it ran and he was convinced that it was
basically we said this is a sasquatch
i'm not going to call teddy roosevelt a
liar chances are it's an indian [ __ ]
with them
[Laughter]
dawn stones enemies probably more that
that'd probably be more likely
but see i would be worried
he he mentions uh uh
he answered that was a skokam skookum
yes
something like that yeah that's like
another name for the same time yeah i
think he may i think he's meant to he i
think he mentioned it might have been
skookum which is skokum which is
what the indians had told her but that
might have been the indians [ __ ] with
him they might have told him about
skulcum and then the next day when i
never [ __ ] with him there's no telling
i'd have been a lot more impressed if
um instead of just like a little rock
into the fire they'd thrown like a big
[ __ ] boulder that nobody could have
picked up or like a huge like a whole
entire tree
then that maybe would have been a little
bit more convincing although like i said
some stories have said that
you know they they have uprooted entire
trees and like stacked them and things
like that the great great hunter stories
great white hunter stories were 1800s
basically kind of british in origin and
they didn't have anything to do with
like getting laid
talking about the victorian era you know
they've been a totally wilder story
[ __ ] roosevelt says yeah they threw
the stones and i looked and i saw a
beautiful hairy woman
built like a brick [ __ ] house
and she grabbed me and i i couldn't fend
her off
she threw the ass on me
getting hit with a tidal wave of ass
so that was it you know i couldn't
handle it i just had to just i just had
to batten down the hatches and write it
out
and he was the best lay of my life
and i i had to keep it from the wife i
couldn't explain it to her that i got
raped by a skull
she was bad though bad ass
later on i heard that there was a skull
that looked a lot like me i was just
gonna say glasses and everything that
would have been the whole it was born
yeah yeah you had glasses and everything
that would have been a great white
hunter story if the 1800s had been
modern times
that that that's the kind of story that
[ __ ] roosevelt would have made up
that does sound like something he would
have said yeah yeah
i got prodigy out there somewhere
but ninjas
spread out in the skulcum population
even interspecies
[Laughter]
love is love
[Laughter]
i like it very progressive teddy
well like i said i kind of feel like
there's probably a whole i'm sure
there's probably a whole sub-genre of
sasquatch porn i mean there's got to be
right there's a whole sub-genre of like
vampires and there's a whole sub-genre
probably has that [ __ ]
oh my god does chuck tingle have any
sasquatch probably i think he does
he's kind of more like a unicorn guy but
i think he has a bunch of sasquatch ones
too now that i'm like thinking danny
goes facebook can mention the vietnam
vietnam rock throwing apes that's right
there was another one uh legend that
some guys are out on [ __ ] ambush
and some rocks with some apes with all
rocks at them
nobody knows if it's true
what was true though is there was the
guys on ambush one time and then they
pulled off the ambush and fell asleep in
the middle of the night they heard a
scream and when they woke up they all
woke up [ __ ]
grabbed their m16s and one dude was gone
he's gone turned down yeah he it what it
was it's a tiger tiger [ __ ] grabbed
him in his sleep and drug him off
tiger tracks leading out probably not
one of the ways that you want to die i'm
not saying there's a good way but i'm
sure that's probably one of the
relationships cracked up on him and bit
him on the back of the neck and [ __ ]
jumped off with him yeah
man snack yeah hey you're just a snack
to them
that's really just saying that i'm a
brony
[Laughter]
i don't even think he knew what a brony
was until we went until we watched that
uh yeah my little pony the toys that
made this episode
nicholas was saying it's not a legend
that vietnamese still see him to this
day
yeah like i said it's
i don't know i'm on the fence about this
one i mean i'm way more over on the side
of the fence we're probably not but
he's never said they were sasquatch said
they were apes
yeah but if somebody came forward and
like with one it was like here it is and
it wasn't like determined to be a hoax
as every single one of them has been so
far um then i'll be like okay fair
enough but
uh gadgey3 says there is neanderthal in
all of us to be fair that's true um yeah
we do have two percent neanderthal dna
at least most of us do
um you know because there was a certain
segment that came out of africa and then
kind of uh mixed in with the
neanderthals
so you know haha you got to put bronies
in the in cell show
if we end up doing the intel show it's
in the poll i haven't checked the poll
because the poll which went up this
morning
i usually wait until sunday afternoon
and then see how the poll goes but yeah
i'm kind of hoping that we're going to
do that one because that one's
will be depressing and enraging and also
hilarious probably an equal measure
uh no one says
uh no news on tila yeah we were
wondering about her like right before so
yeah so i kind of feel like most of the
evidence
and there was this one dude um who's in
a lot of the monster quest shows and he
was on like a lot of documentaries about
it he's like an anthropologist i guess
and he had a big collection
of all of these casts of footprints
now
he's kind of like well i have all these
different ones and they're all from
different eras and different you know
locations and blah blah blah like how
could all of these have been faked but
i don't know i feel like a lot of them
could be like because they know that
some of them for sure were faked because
some people like you know put on big
[ __ ] bigfoot feet and go out and make
bigfoot footprints
for the and then some of the footprints
too i kind of feel like are probably
just animals that people are
misidentifying
i'm leveling up you're leveling up
you're putting on your sexual
tyrannosaurus actually that's your
sexual bigfoot yeah after talking about
teddy [ __ ] and making up teddy porn
and [ __ ] with him and the [ __ ]
bigfoot girl look at that anymore yeah i
mean i gotta have a [ __ ] put
teddy sasquatch porn yeah i'm gonna have
to put my [ __ ] sexual tyranno
oh my
you're
god
what do you look cute yeah they look
cute yeah you look cute
[Laughter]
what you had to ask me though
he's like fishing for compliments he's
fishing for kaplan yeah we shaved my
back today that's true so you know of
course yeah if you guys weren't here
if you guys weren't here at the very
beginning of the show but i told you you
should have left the hair on at least
until the show was over
i couldn't i couldn't believe that i was
shocked
i was teasing that [ __ ] just grew in a
matter of a couple of days
like i said maybe you're in the
sasquatch well we kind of like we kind
of a while back we were thrown around
the idea of
making
a skunk ape video because like i said if
you're in the if you're in florida
louisiana area um you know we have a
sasquatchy creature too but it's called
the skunk ape uh which is similar in
pretty much every way except it's like
super stinky
um and so i used to make jokes that tom
was the skunk ape and then that we were
gonna make like a fake video about it
but
after reading about all of the people
that have been injured in the course of
doing bigfoot hoax videos uh probably
not the best idea
matter of fact i think it was 2012
there was a dude where was it at i think
it was montana
there was a dude who was wearing a
ghillie suit and he was making a bigfoot
hoax video like hoping it would go viral
and he got run over by a car and killed
wouldn't it be easier to narrow body
hair the thing about nair though is that
i've used it before it like really
smells
yeah it does look like a burning hair
no it smells no it smells like
sulfur sulfur dj maniac sends some food
we'll see there you go
[Laughter]
yeah just uh
yeah the skunk ape is uh where was i
skunk is teenage sasquatch with the axe
body spray yeah that's probably what it
is
uh yeah so
like i said and and a lot of the um
the footprints that they found too kind
of had claws on them which kind of makes
me feel like i'm not saying all of the
sightings are a bear um but i think a
lot of the sightings are probably a bear
like walking on their back feet you know
what i'm saying
uh thank you no need for me too
tom squat
tom squatch
[Laughter]
he says hey wig maybe i know which wig
do you have that looks the most like a
sasquatch probably the mullet one i
would imagine no sasquatch be the
[ __ ] big old big one the big old big
one the big old big one
which one is that the one that people
call it my heavy metal wig oh i kind of
feel like the the mullet one would be
better because well because
the the heavy metal one is black though
and
sasquatch is supposed to be like brown
or like reddish brown or some people
have even seen a gray one although
that's not very common i kind of feel
like it's mostly like brown you know
what i mean
but yeah so
as i mentioned earlier you know
stories about a sasquatch like creature
wild hairy eight-man type thing
um
go back a really long way okay i'm not
saying that means that they're you know
real or anything like that but i'm just
saying they do go back like way before
you know the popular conception of
bigfoot started
i mean there's even like um there's this
place called
uh painted rock in california on the
tool river indian reservation
and there's um some petroglyphs on there
that sort of thank you nicodemus
i like the hippo with the oh yeah thank
you very much that's crazy i want to
thank you very much
[Laughter]
you don't even have the elvis wake up no
i'll get okay i'll get ready man okay
you guys are pushing me to put wigs on
it with wigs happening when it happened
it's too early
the show's just started the show's just
started
i'm still i still haven't even finished
the first drink yet i haven't either
yeah i'm trying to go like a little bit
slower like i said because we're gonna
have to drive we might have to go out
after so it's almost selling too
is it oh yeah yeah no need for me to
send a dollar nine nine times watch
spell check yeah because
but i knew what you meant though i knew
what you meant
uh but yeah so there's these petroglyphs
on this rock
that are supposedly between
500 1000 years old and some people say
that the petroglyphs kind of look like a
little family of like bigfoots big feet
something bigfoots
um
and supposedly according to the people
that live in the area that the biggest
one they call it um
the hairy man or something meaning this
a similar thing
so
as we were talking about earlier a lot
of cultures around the world have these
sorts of stories about
big hairy
ape men
whether that means that they really
existed at some point whether that means
thank you esther thank you tom for the
red sun movie suggestion i like the
movie very very much charles bronson and
toshira mufune can't go wrong thank you
very much that's a great movie it's one
of my favorite westerns yeah
it's half western half samurai
movie which is there's very similar
genres
from two cultures that in some ways kind
of admire each other
and
that movie in a way is very much like
the inspiration for the very first star
wars movie which was also part samurai
movie part western it's good a jedi was
a samurai
basically a [ __ ]
han solo was a it was was a gunfighter
basically
something out of a western movie good
movies good good concepts you guys
should see red sun it's on free on
youtube
victor says tom you need a mohawk wig
yeah i heard it i agree
uh and also thank you victor a group of
bigfoots is called a blurry
maybe it should be
big feet that's what i'm going to call
them a group of big feets
you know abrasive big feets
i like that
but uh yeah so so like i said this kind
of goes back a long way and there's like
a lot of native american legends about
something very much like a sasquatch
creature like i said i don't know if
that means that they something like that
existed or existed a long time ago or
something but i'm just saying i'm just
putting that out there hold on one
second what's that esther if you like
red sun go ahead and buy that damn
or or rent
the um lone wolf and cubs series you'll
like it it's good
yeah yeah
so you know so but there are like
regional variations i guess or like
tribal variations of what
because some of the um just kind of like
nowadays some of the legends that they
have about these kind of creatures like
some of them are like pretty chill
and they just kind of like live in the
woods and don't hurt anybody some of
them are more aggressive
you know [ __ ] like that
um some of them are cannibals yeah so
it's kind of like there and i want to
talk i'll talk about this a little bit
later but apparently there was this
thing that happened in 1924
um
there was supposedly a bunch of miners
who were out there you know working at a
mine or whatever and uh there was a
little bit of a confrontation between
them and some group of eight men there
was some rock throwing involved there
was some [ __ ] like that don't know how
true that was but you know because like
i said it's from 1924 it was in a
newspaper uh back then dom the bomb said
if you're in the uk you need a vpn to
watch red sun on youtube thank you
yeah
finding red sun on dvd or blu-ray is
near impossible i tried to find it it
was expensive even on dvd it's hard to
find
and i think it's the old aspect ratios
they need to reboot that movie or redo
it it's a great charles bronson movie
yeah yeah
i mean i would like if i recommend
getting a vpn just because i really like
that i've been able to like watch i mean
it's not really expensive it was like 80
bucks for two years
so it's kind of like and you can watch
anything like shutter and like youtube
and [ __ ] like that in other countries
and it's like totally easy so yeah yeah
it's called it's called the lone wolf
and cub it was the inspiration for uh
the mandalorian
yeah about samurai and his little son
yeah what's this what's his son's name
again
yeah and uh that kid is like so [ __ ]
there's like six movies six of them
right baby cart to hell and [ __ ] path
to hell
and it was based on an anime as a uh
they condensed all six movies down into
one [ __ ] crazy movie called shogun
assassin which is bonkers
but the original six movies they're
[ __ ] great it was shintaro katsu's
brother
yeah played the i love those shows yeah
and he was the dude who played zawichi
yeah but uh i got the criterion
collection i think was close to a
hundred dollars but it was it was worth
it actually six months gorgeous i love
it
it's like it's coming back from ancient
japan it's all in parchment and [ __ ]
with effectively feels like folds all
out yeah right it's nice
yeah i mean they want me in criterion
collection they like freaking they
really like do this [ __ ] right you know
i need to watch those movies again
yeah because we sat down and watched
them like from like yeah a while back
yeah so this is the story that okay so
we were talking about teddy roosevelt
earlier yeah so apparently he wrote a
book in 1893 called the wilderness
hunter because of course it was now he
says i don't know if he says this
happened to him but he's saying that he
heard a story by this dude that he knew
named bauman he was like a mountain man
and he baumann said that he that there
was this like
essentially a sasquatch that was like
you know bipedal and he really stunk
really bad and that he came to his
trapping camp he was trapping beavers
and kind of like stalked after him like
chased him
and then
um ended up breaking one dude's neck and
like killing him
so
i don't so like i said i don't know if
teddy roosevelt necessarily saw the [ __ ]
or if he was just like repeating a story
that he told you know what i'm saying
yeah but that's where that story came
from
um so like i said there's there's been
other ones where
you know the worst thing that the
sasquatches do is just like steal other
people's fish out of their nets or
something like that but like i said
there's been somewhere they've been kind
of aggressive to i feel like
recently
um
i don't know i feel like it's kind of
like
i don't i don't know if i'd say 50 50
but most of the time we're just like oh
you know they they just kind of like
chill and don't do anything but a lot of
them
some of the documentaries they saw
people that saw them said that they
would kind of like bluff like a gorilla
but that they wouldn't like attack you
like if you were just kind of like bowed
back up at them they'd run away type of
thing but i don't know
so yeah so like i said this goes back
to
uh there was like back in the 1920s
there was this dude who was um
he was like worked for indian affairs
back then and he took all these stories
of the these local sasquatch legends and
like sightings and stuff and he put them
in like he wrote a series of articles
for the newspaper in canada in a for a
newspaper in canada and um so these were
all all kinds of different sightings and
stuff
and
he noted in these articles that the
indigenous peoples you know the natives
were like really they were like
insistent that these creatures were real
and they were like really offended by
people saying that they didn't really
exist right
um
now these people said that the
sasquatches they didn't really call them
that that was just like a name somebody
else gave them just to kind of because
they you know different tribes had
different names for them but these
particular uh sightings they said that
these sasquatches could talk
um
at least to some extent so they were
more man-like i guess than animal-like
so at this point it was around like 1940
i think when the terminology sasquatch
like came into popular usage and that
was supposedly from you know one
particular name
uh and i'm just not even gonna try to
pronounce it but it's like s-a-s-q-e-c
uh was you know like a native term for
quick yeah something like that so so
it's kind of like an anglicized version
of that word and that's kind of what
they started calling it uh vince forward
but i feel like the modern
our modern conception of bigfoot or
sasquatch or anything like first kind of
came
into popularity i guess in the late
1950s
so there's this dude named jerry crew
and he
was a bulldozer operator like for a
logging company and this was humboldt
county california which like i said
humboldt county
uh mendocino county
trinity like this which is called the
emerald triangle because that's where
they grow the pot um that's like kind of
a hotbed of sasquatch sightings uh so
there's that so even back in the old
days i don't know if it was
if it was because that's where the story
came from i don't know but so this dude
back in 1958 he apparently found a bunch
of
big
sort of human like think uh fingerprints
footprints uh except they were like 16
inches long
and he found it uh he found like a track
you know tracks in the mud
now he told his co-workers about this
and then a bunch of his people that he
was working with said yeah we've seen
those too
um and we've also seen those tracks on
previous sites and we don't know what
they are because they look like human
footprints but they're like way bigger
than a person's footprint would be um
some of them also reported some other
stuff like really heavy [ __ ] like big
like 450 pound oil drums like being
moved around like when no one was
supposed to be on the job site [ __ ] like
that
now
because of the footprints
they started using and i even saw like
their pictures online of um the the
actual original newspaper story where
this dude reported these sightings and
he started calling it they they started
calling it bigfoot because it had big
feet
so
that's the name that kind of like caught
on like i said so sasquatch comes from
the 40s
uh the bigfoot name comes from the late
50s
and pretty much i feel like those two
terms are pretty much interchangeable
right at this stage um but yeah that's
kind of like what it was
so
where okay i was going to show them this
guy okay this is what i was talking
about
it's called lone wolf and cub
it's six movies
this is the criterion edition
all right and it opens up this thing is
badass it was expensive
it was worth it
oh is it this way here it is
see these guys little baby on the back
yeah and it opens up
and it comes with a little book hi pokey
and the book has
okay you dab it
don't sit on her she might jump up in
the chair behind you here's diagonal
diagonal was the prototype for baby yoda
okay that cute little booger yeah
his little hair and there's his dad
[Laughter]
you see
he's got a little
lone wolf and cup
and they're trying to
they're escaping from
a death sentence
that the shogun put on them
but this was the inspiration basically
for the mandalorian
the names of the movies are
sword of vengeance
baby cart
at the river styx
baby cart to hades
baby cart what does that say i can't
read that
in peril baby cart in peril was a baby
car baby cart in the land of
demons yeah yeah and then what's this
one white heaven in hell white heaven
and hell's the last one yeah this is a
very good series
and
all six movies you can get for probably
probably around 80 90 100 depending on
how rare it is it was a limited edition
i think
but you could also probably stream them
i would imagine really recommend it one
movie
they took all these movies
and shrunk them down into one [ __ ]
crazy ass b-movie called the shogun
assassin which has nothing to do with
this
and makes absolutely no sense it makes
no sense but this makes sense when you
watch this
tom criterion collection what title it's
actually six movies it's the movie it's
the lone wolf and cub series yeah long
wolf and cub yeah they're like samurai
movies yeah
inspiration for the mandalorian
that's what we were talking about yeah
but yeah so all right so where was i so
1958 like i said this you know dude on
this construction site like for he
worked for a logging company and
apparently found these big ass
footprints hence the name bigfoot
however in 2002
um
the family members
of a co-worker who worked with uh
who worked with jerry crew
whose name was ray wallace
said that ray wallace had actually made
the footprints himself like he had
carved these big wooden feet
and like walked through the job sites
like for a joke
um don't know if that's true but
that's what his family said after he
died anyway they're like yeah sorry we
just we were pretty much responsible for
that
uh you know and you'll find that a lot
of times
uh
most famously i guess uh with the most
famous uh video clip
of a supposed sasquatch the patterson
gimlin film which was taken in 1967.
yeah i remember when this thing we saw
this like on in search of it's the first
time i saw it i kind of they even put it
like in the opening like the intro of in
search of did they not kind of had me
and my dad going i was a little kid i
was cub he was long wolf at the time
and i'm looking at that and my dad's
going yeah maybe maybe yeah because back
in those days it was still kind of
possible
before you know widespread satellites
and yeah before we can like see
everything square inch of the earth
yeah he thought maybe that might be
not anymore though
danny rowling ghostbase says the jeffrey
combs bigfoot film abominable is a great
bigfoot horror film i just i've been
wanting to see that i actually didn't
even realize that jeffrey combs was in
that yeah i do kind of feel like a lot
of bigfoot movies have come out lately
like i said there was a lot of them in
the 70s you had a little boggy creek
yeah which is more based on they don't
call it a sasquatch that's more based on
like the falc monster is a falc
f-o-u-k-e i don't know what year was
that man if that's got jeffrey combs
they got to see it i don't think it's
that old because i remember like hearing
about it a while back and then there was
that one that bobcat gold weight one um
[ __ ] uh willow creek which i've heard
was like pretty good i think that might
be on tubey and i've been wanting to
watch that when it's on my list i just
haven't gotten around to it yet but you
know we'll see how it is
but yeah so
the patterson gimlin film which like i
said still the most famous piece of
bigfoot uh video that was taken uh
1967. now i think roger patterson is
dead now
but robert gimlin they actually
interviewed him
so i guess he's still alive because they
actually interviewed him for the um
that uh sasquatch miniseries that was on
hulu that like i said wasn't entirely
about sasquatch it was more about like
drug dealers in the emerald triangle
but they they interviewed him a bit and
he
is still like insistent
that that was a real bigfoot they were
out like riding their horses or whatever
and they just saw this fema and it's
actually a female bigfoot they said
because it had boobies yeah but uh that
it was walking and it turned around and
looked at them and they were like
freaking out it's like oh we gotta
record it and blah blah
um you know it's only like a minute long
but
also on that same documentary there's
this dude named bob hieronymus i think
is his name
and he kind of came out and he said no
that was me
in the suit
um and
it's funny because he was saying on the
on the documentary he's like
so he's like uh
bob gimlin he's like just lives kind of
down the street from me like in the same
neighborhood and it's like so we don't
really talk anymore it's like every time
he'll drive by and he'll kind of wave
but it's like they don't really because
i guess because he's still insisting
that this that the bigfoot thing was
real and he's saying no that was me in a
suit okay um
uh b just posted a uh link to lone wolf
and cub on youtube but that is not the
movies that is the television series oh
okay dominic it's not the same dom the
bomb said that you can get it on blu-ray
in the uk now
for uh 64 pounds limited edition
okay
that's not bad
that's not bad yeah they're actually
all right i'm gonna run to okay do we
have any
yeah let me show the strange realities
of a commercial again and i'm just going
to like run to the bathroom real quick
then we'll kind of come back and we'll
talk about some
kind of recent sightings of some sets
well in the past like 10 20 years that's
fairly recent all right so we'll be
right back in just a second
in 2019 the first strange realities
conference took place in nashville
tennessee the pandemic in turmoil the
following year could not stop 2020's
conference from thriving in cyberspace
as a live streaming event now for 2021
the third annual strange realities
conference will combine these worlds
into a paranormal hybrid event live in
person in nashville and streaming online
join us in exploring just how truly
strange our reality can be with an
interdimensional line-up of speakers
presenting unique and intellectual
perspectives on magic mysteries and the
paranormal
featuring
greenfield dr j michael bennett aka dr
future tim bernal soraya azcat dr
stephen finley aaron gullius amy pachule
brent raines chris ernst heather mosher
michael hughes jose herrera joshua
cutchen kiki
nathan isaac pd newman steven snyder aka
recluse david metcalf timothy renner
steve stockton and friend collier
tickets available on strange
realitiesconference.com
it's gonna be amazing
[Music]
okay and we are back
yeah the uh the link that um
b posted was actually the uh the
television series
um there it's it's not it's not the same
movies that's good that it's come down
some on blu-ray
i don't know if that's the criteria in
addition or not probably not but um
it wouldn't matter the uh
um
the remasters came out really nice it's
a good looking movie
fun to watch
yeah and it's a it's an anime movie so
it has comic book
kind of quality to it you'll see it's
good yeah yeah so all right so we were
just talking about lone wolf club yeah
yeah yeah okay um all right so we're
talking about as i mentioned i kind of
feel like a lot of sightings of
sasquatch are from the pacific northwest
or you know western canada type of area
although there are some from other areas
too like some in texas or princeton ohio
wisconsin montana
there'd been a [ __ ] ton in florida
actually um but like i said down here we
call it skunk ape
um you know so there's that whole thing
so let's talk about
some
sightings
now some of these i pulled a lot of
these just off of um there's a
there's a thing called bfro which is
like the bigfoot field research
organization i think is what it stands
for and they have a massive website that
has like over 2 000 uh reported
sightings on it so i just pulled some of
these off of here some of them have
locations some of them not
uh so you know
still not enough likes up there somebody
said yeah
all right so here's one that happened in
january of 2008.
so there's a guy and he's driving a semi
and he was driving a truck full of
potatoes actually
um
in utah
so he's going down this hill right and
then the fog it's kind of like thick fog
so he's
driving through the fog and then he
notices something on the side of the
road and its eyes were glowing like i
said there was eye shine so at first he
thought it was a deer which is what you
would think uh because we see the other
side right here as well so i'm assuming
they do everywhere else
now uh at that he switched on his high
beams
and said that he saw a massive
creature
running across the road uh just 20 feet
or so away from his truck like running
in with long strides
he thought
that the creature was
had to be at least eight feet tall if
not taller
um he thought maybe 600 to 800 pounds in
weight he said it had black hair
big
eyebrows and big long arms that were
longer than a human's
um he said that it turned its head and
looked at the truck as it was driving
across and he said that he had had to
swerve into the middle of the road to
avoid hitting it um and it almost
crashed
but he stopped he said he managed to
like stop the truck like 200 300 yards
down the road and looked back to see
what it was but he didn't see it
now
he said
apparently this guy he's not named
but he said he was a hunter he was an
outdoorsman he was familiar with
the animals of the area he said he had
never thought that bigfoot existed and i
feel like a lot of people say this um
but then he saw one and he said that it
scared the hell out of him that was the
quote it scared the hell out of me
so that was one that happened in uh utah
like i said this is from the bfro
website the bigfoot field research
organization like i said so i pulled a
lot of these off of there
just to get like a little smattering of
like some recent [ __ ]
so here was one that happened in
september of 2009.
now this woman was driving to her job
this was actually in colorado
and she um was going through
independence pass
and she was kind of like tired because
it was like early in the morning so she
pulls her car or truck over to the side
of the road uh to kind of like rest a
minute or something she gets out of the
truck and then she sees there's like a
meadow in front of her and she saw like
something moving around she thought it
was a bear at first uh but then she said
the creature stood up and saw that its
arms hung down like a person's arms uh
and so she
imagined that it was not a bear she said
that it was um
she said it really was really really big
and that its hair was kind of like
brownish red
um and also had
big ass boobs
so it was yeah so he's going that way
yeah yeah no this is a woman that saw
this one
yeah you were thinking some other thing
like so
some guy like stopped and was like man i
wish that monster
you're right i could get it over here
girl just like teddy roosevelt yeah
right
it seemed like teddy roosevelt
heterosexual powerball
[ __ ] the
swatches is [ __ ] ted
squash [ __ ] said he can't help it
well you know maybe it was a sexy maybe
this is a heterosexual power bottle
going squatching yeah i love do you know
that they okay so that show finding
bigfoot
i remember when that show first started
what the [ __ ] channel is that on is that
a discovery or discovery history or tlc
or something like that on his history
channel
yeah it might have been
figures oh yeah how far this [ __ ]
have fallen but yeah so um
i did not realize that show has been on
for i think 11 seasons have they ever
found bigfoot no they have not no so you
know i i i will submit that that title
is a little bit of a misnomer i got i
gotta admit though i think some of those
television proofs are not trying to find
bigfoot well if they found bigfoot the
show would be over yeah they're like all
right you found them it's cancelled
remember the one that we saw that we saw
the uh
this is towards the end of television's
reign i i think television is [ __ ]
dead all right
very rare are you gonna [ __ ] watch
anything on television remember the one
where they had the rednecks dressing up
to [ __ ] what's it called the hunt
killing sasquatch or killing bigfoot i
think it's what it was called yeah was
it called killing bigfoot
i think it was called killing bigfoot
yeah and i was kind of like oh i gotta
see this yeah yeah even though i knew
nothing was gonna we just saw the damn
we just saw that trailer i think we
saw bits of it
rednecks digging holes and putting
[ __ ] covers over and popping up out
with shotguns and you this obvious role
playing
well i'm just having a good time yeah
obviously they're [ __ ] around lights
and [ __ ] they're just like well okay now
is it jump up is it finding bigfoot
i don't remember because i've only seen
like a couple episodes is it finding
bigfoot with like the group of rednecks
that every single episode they invent a
new bigfoot finding device
of
it's like and this is the one i invented
this time yeah that it's like and they
invent some like
i don't know what they're doing kind of
they were trying to market that [ __ ] to
the lowest common denominator i mean who
is watching this
who is somebody was watching it for 11
seasons or it wouldn't have been
who is watching this
it must be overweight
60 year old 70 year old women
in shotgun shacks in louisiana
with a cable connection and a fan
blowing on them no ac just a fan blowing
on them and them loving on these guys
oh he's cute oh he's cute yeah he gonna
catch that question
mama mama come on in here
[Laughter]
look what he's wearing he's got us he's
got his hat on yeah yeah he's gonna
switch some [ __ ] he's got his camouflage
i think it was more like a replacement
for [ __ ] um
uh what do you call it
um
like jesse
jesse lake now what was her name [ __ ]
ricky ricky lake yeah it's like it's
like from the ricky lake crowd
maybe i think i think the daytime talk
shows [ __ ] went away and they were
replaced with that i just don't know and
it's kind of and i kind of have the same
thing with like ghost hunter type shows
and there's like a [ __ ] zillion of
those it's like now every time like the
travel channel is all paranormal shows
now as far as i can determine even the
pet channels the animals even the yeah
even like pen even the [ __ ] pet
channel is all oh i think jackson galaxy
is still on which is like i love jackson
galaxy but i subscribe to his youtube
channel this is what he said read it
right where where where oh tv thank you
tv triggers titty roosevelt i think that
show it was mountain monsters also yeah
it might have been i know there's more
than one um i remember finding bigfoot
because i was kind of like i laughed
when that first came out because i was
like finding bigfoot i'm like you guys
aren't gonna pretty sure the other one
was killing bigfoot i think it was
killing i don't know if that was on it's
rednecks dressed up they had and they
had a ridiculous ship there's shotguns
chainsaws
[ __ ] lights on their helmets and
they're going to run around at night
they're going to find a bigfoot and kill
it
i just don't know how somebody could
watch 11 seasons of a bunch of dudes
just wandering around the woods and not
finding anything
but like i said the pit that's the same
reason that i can't really watch the
ghost hunter shows because like how many
times can you watch some people like
creep around a dark house and not find
anything the idea was very good the very
first show is what was it taps
yeah well yeah i mean i think there was
some before that but yeah that was kind
of like i think it was called taps
and um or at least that was the name of
the little program yeah that's the name
of their well that's ghost hunters right
aren't they called towers or is that i
don't know i mix them all up and for the
first couple seasons it was pretty good
i mean they did try to do scientific
like they set up the cameras and they
did show their findings and sometimes
they did have some weird anomalies the
one that i remembered that
did seem like they found something was
the lighthouse they were in this
lighthouse and had a camera up in there
and had a camera station it looked like
there was you could see a little white
you know how low-res like night vision
cameras were about yeah
it looked like something was moving up
around the stairs and then it went
across
but yeah i remember what you're talking
about that was the best thing i ever saw
but that doesn't necessarily mean it was
perfect i don't even think because i
thought for a minute that that might
have been the saint augustine lighthouse
which is supposed to be super haunted
but i don't even think it was that i
think it was a different one because
that lighthouse was out in the middle of
the ocean
oh yeah yeah yeah that's right there
wasn't anything you know that's right i
remember that episode yeah yeah and it
was i think it was abandoned wouldn't it
yeah i think i don't think it was in use
anymore no but you could get to it and
they saw something there
but
there might have been a couple other
ones but i didn't see them but i heard
there was like a couple where they did
get some things on at least they weren't
faking
video evidence well that you know i
don't think well i think they might have
later i think people said that later on
it looked like this someone she was kind
of fishy but the first couple because i
mean i cut if if you were going for like
several seasons and you weren't coming
up with anything i mean obviously you'd
want to fake some [ __ ] well they did the
right thing though they made the show
about the investigators and all the
drama happening between the
investigators not so much about the case
which yeah like i said because you know
if otherwise you're just gonna like i
said it'll just be like a bunch of
people you don't care about wandering
around in like a darkened house going
did you hear that no i didn't hear
anything there was one where they did a
prison
they did an old abandoned prison and it
was pretty damn creepy it looked like
something moved in front of a camera
yeah i remember that episode yeah that
one too that might have been a moth that
could have been a million things yeah
well that you know it was weird-looking
though yeah
they're uh yeah everybody's talking
about love in jackson galaxy he yeah
he's red i love my cat from hell and and
he has a um a youtube channel also which
i subscribe to and he puts up [ __ ] like
all the time and he's like super funny
so it's like so i watch a lot of his
stuff on youtube grandparents says you
can see reruns of fighting bigfoot on
discovery i'm pretty sure there was like
[ __ ] 11 seasons of that [ __ ] 11
seasons yeah of people wandering around
in the woods not finding anything or
being like oh i wonder what this is like
setting up like trail cams and stuff
like that and there's being like a blur
on there
that could totally be bigfoot she rarely
watches tv the only time we watch tv in
any recent history was to see the
walking dead before that [ __ ] went down
the tubes yeah that was like a couple
that was a couple seasons ago though
yeah
there's nothing on tv worth watching
well the things that are worth watching
you can see them other places like i
said you know i watch series and movies
all the time but i don't watch them on
tv i watch it
is dead i watch them on netflix or hulu
or something or to be or something i
heard you can get a chick cable channel
for only a few thousand dollars a month
now oh boy we can have our own kids yeah
your own cable channel nobody's watching
it we can put a bunch of well that's
about you get more hits on youtube you
can put all kind of stupid [ __ ] on there
yeah
grantham's hammer said they never find
anything on that oak island show either
but it's on season after season yeah see
it's like i don't i and honestly i like
a lot of shows about like mysteries like
history's mysteries and like what's that
one mysteries at the museum where it's
like a bunch of different [ __ ] like a
bunch of different stories on one thing
that's like fascinating but that's like
real [ __ ] so i kind of feel like if
we're just gonna have
and i can't believe that there's like
multiple shows
about ghost hunting where it's like and
i like that it's you know it's i guess
some people just like the whole creepy
because i like a haunting and stuff but
that at least has
reenactments so it's almost kind of like
watching a a scary movie it's not like
you're really you're talking about how
much the [ __ ] [ __ ] in search what in
search of was what was this [ __ ] because
it had a badass [ __ ] intro yeah it
had leonard nimoy doing the voiceovers
which gave it gravitas so creepy and it
was just vague enough to leave you
wondering what the [ __ ] that was about
yeah they never really got into a bunch
of details generalities and just the
reenactments were kind of low budget
cheap cheap creepy
and the thing about it is that they kind
of talked about um you know they talked
about a bunch of bullshitty stuff but
they talked about like a variety of
things yeah some of it was real stuff
they were talking about yeah so some of
it was like real mysterious things so
like i said i'm more interested in that
kind of show than
just let's watch a bunch of people
wander around in the woods looking for
something that's probably not there like
i don't it's like it's not it's it just
doesn't i don't know
it would have the same impact on a
younger person i think it was it may
have been a bit of a nostalgia if you're
in your 40s 50s maybe 30s you could get
kind of creeped out about it but you
could investigate it now what they're
talking about online and find out more
information than what they gave you
which would dispel a lot of the
a lot of the mystery of what they're
talking about like the coral castles we
haven't seen it it's around here it's
it's downtown now isn't it town's
sprung up around the coral castles
but in in search of it makes it sound
bigger and more mysterious than it
really is if you see it you go oh no one
dude could make this
i kind of want to do a show about that
one of these days because that's like
that's kind of like a famous florida
weird thing yeah um and i think it only
was weird because later on people were
like no man i saw the dude and he like
levitated
no but i've heard people that have seen
it in person they'll go oh no it's
obviously made by man
yeah i've seen pictures of it it's like
i think one dude could make that if he
was not that as big as their city if he
was uh determined yeah and he had the
equipment he knew how to do work with
stone yeah so yeah it wasn't that crazy
no thank you dom the bomb watch lcd on
prime it's so good okay we will uh yeah
and dexter starts up in november on show
time okay yeah we're gonna have to
definitely see that because i really
really like dexter
uh all right so here's another one that
happened back in uh 2010
so there's this dude and he's a deer
hunter and it's kind of early in the
morning it's like seven in the morning
so he um is going hunting that day so he
parks his car whatever
on the trail and then he goes into the
woods
and he says that while he's walking to
his spot where he was gonna hunt some
deer he said he saw a really big animal
walking about 10 yards ahead of him
and he said that
he'd seen bear before he said it's
definitely not a bear he did say it was
walking really fast and wasn't making
any noise
uh he said he thought it was about seven
and a half feet tall
uh weighed about 500 pounds he said it
had dark fur
that it was like really muscular had
long arms and was kind of hunched over
now he said that he was pretty sure that
it wasn't a bear because he'd seen them
before um so like i said you're you're
getting a lot of these types of things
and this was fairly recently that was
2010. so here's one that is a a skunk
ape here's one that happened in florida
all right and the swamps
so this happened in may of
2011. so apparently there was a guy he
was well there's pokey
it's the elusive pookie foot
[Laughter]
you know what's up she kind of jumped
down you just relax
she's like no i don't want to be up here
i have to move around just relax
she doesn't she doesn't want to roll she
never relaxes she's a little spaz
yeah she's like i want to tear stuff up
yeah look at everybody can see pookie
oh we're talking about sasquatch bookie
she doesn't care she doesn't know what
to say ask about you
yeah she's seen dogs that's it yeah
she's not happy about that
but yeah so
yeah oh pokey she's chilling out now a
little bit trying to for a second
where's your foot put your foot here
yeah pookie foot okay
so yeah so this one happened in florida
like i said
thank you david june hale pookie yay
president titty roosevelt
we'll buy you some more treats with it
yeah and some more toys yeah yeah she's
like all right
yeah
so so this one happened in florida so i
guess there's like a fishing guide right
and he had two dudes in his um
flat boat which is like in a mangrove
swamp so i'm assuming this was somewhere
in like southern florida like the
everglades or somewhere
so they're um they're going to now
apparently the two guys that were in the
boat with him one of them was a lawyer
and one of them was like an airline
pilot so you know
these are supposedly like more
uh credible witnesses i guess then
hey i was driving a couple of bums
around or a couple of like meth addicts
and we saw a bigfoot so i guess it's
like more believable but yeah so they
saw something about a hundred yards away
on the shore like uh of you know the
swamp where they were going through now
uh at first again thought maybe a bear
or maybe a feral hog because we do have
those uh in florida i don't know if you
know we do have wild pigs so
you know so he thought maybe it was that
but as the boat kind of approached um
he said the the thing stood up
and it looked at them and at that point
he knew that it was not a bear and that
it was not a pig either um he said i
love this he said it was as wide as a
refrigerator that's what he said uh he
said it had a zz top beard which is
which is my favorite detail uh and also
that he had a hairless forehead so he
got i guess he was kind of like bald on
the top and yeah
he was balding in the front like
looking for some crawfish or something
it might have been that with the bigs it
might have been like crunchy
yeah jimmy clap jimmy aka
aka crenshaw from the boggy creek 2 and
the legend continues
all right but yeah with that with that
big belly and the yeah and the overalls
with one yeah with one strap he's out
there doing his nudest thing [ __ ]
around in the mud and [ __ ] oh need to
come off and maybe he was like i gotta
go he was like super hairy he's also
been taking testosterone so he's growing
hair all over his body and he doesn't
bother to shave it he doesn't have he
doesn't have somebody around like to
shave all his back hair
there's tila hey where the [ __ ] you been
god damn
i thought you got killed over there over
there in a [ __ ] over there in san
francisco in a big old pile of
human waste and [ __ ] hypodermic
needles from all those bumps taking over
san francisco where the hell you been
but yeah so this was one that was found
in florida like i said
you know yeah maybe it was a skunk gate
but like you said it was probably just
some dude living in the swamp honestly
it was just like going out for his
morning constitutional
perhaps yeah
um
so yeah
uh here's another one that happened in
2010 this was october of 2010.
so there's a dude and he's supposedly in
his house uh watching tv or whatever he
said she killed i'm unkillable
i hope so you missed it [ __ ] jenny
shaved my back
she should have been here well not on
camera not on camera that would be a
little maybe a little much make all
kinds of money
you think
i don't know maybe in some segments of
the area yeah you would
i just said she's been busy yeah
yeah tila is almost as elusive as the
sasquatch yeah that's right she only you
know uh so yeah so this guy's like
watching tv in his house and he hears a
noise outside
he said that at first it sounded like a
police siren or like a car horn
but then when he turned the volume on
the tv down he said it was actually
sounded more like an injured animal
and at first he thought maybe it's a
bear or maybe it's a mountain lion
something like that
um but then he just sort of forgot about
it so then the next night
um his friend comes over and is gonna
take him they're gonna go out like
gambling at a casino or something like
that so the friend comes to pick him up
about eight o'clock
and they had driven a couple of miles
and then they both heard the same noise
now they were kind of like i wonder what
that is that's like a weird ass noise
and then they like kept driving but then
they there was a car ahead of them that
had stopped like in the middle of the
road because apparently the two people
in the car head had also heard the noise
and was like what the [ __ ] was that and
it's like stopped
and then when they stopped they saw
there was like this creature that looked
like a man they said it looked ten feet
tall
um dark brown black hair and again
eyes that glowed uh in the reflection
from their headlights and they said they
saw the dude or they saw the creature
for whatever for about 30 seconds and
then it started walking off
um and they said the way it walked was
real and this is something that i've
heard described a lot like a bunch of
people that said that they've seen these
and it's weird because this seems like a
more maybe a more recent phenomenon
because a lot of people
when i saw some recent documentaries a
lot of them said that the way that the
sasquatch of the apparent sasquatch
walked was that it walked really fluidly
they said it wasn't like a person but it
wasn't really like
like an ape either like you know how
apes kind of have that walk like that
they said it was almost kind of like in
between but not quite
um that it was almost kind of like a
gliding
type of motion and that's also uh what
this person said that they saw they said
that the movement was very fluid or
gliding and that it just kind of like
walked off um but yeah so they did uh so
these two did actually you know say
later yeah we never believed in bigfoot
but blah blah now we think we saw one
now this one actually came from a
police officer
this happened in 2007
and i guess he had got like a call out
to go to this ranch or whatever and then
when he was driving out to it he sees
something coming up out of a ravine like
on the side of the road
and he thought at first that it was a
person this was somewhere where there
was like a lot of marijuana
fields you know like people growing it
out in the woods and stuff so he thought
that it was somebody like
freaking out or like running out or
whatever but so he hits the brake on the
car and backs up and then in this
headlights he says that he saw
again a creature that was about seven
feet tall
with brown fur walking upright they said
it had leaves and grass matted into the
fur on its back like it had been lying
down and was kind of moving slowly they
said it kind of turned away from the cop
and went back into the you know the
forest kind of pushing aside some small
tree limbs and he said it was visible
for only a few seconds but he could hear
a lot of the noise that it was making
for a lot longer and he also believes
that this was a sasquatch
um yeah so the same thing too
some people like i said some people have
said they saw these outside of their
houses right so this person uh this was
actually in virginia which is somewhere
which i don't think has a lot of bigfoot
sightings generally
but uh this was a dude and his son
and it was kind of early in the morning
and the two of them
uh this was may 2011 by the way they
said they heard a loud noise outside
their house so they thought it was like
a person or like an intruder so they get
their guns
and they go outside to see who it is um
you know thinking someone's breaking in
or it's a bear or something like that
so they said when they got outside they
said that actually it was an eight-foot
tall furry humanoid
uh running at them from the woods behind
the house
um
and they shot at it although well the
sun kind of shot into the air
um and they said that the creature made
a shrieking noise but kept running
toward them
they said they the creature got within
15 feet of them and then the pair were
like [ __ ] this and ran back into their
house uh they both said they were like
terrified
um again they said that this creature
like smelled like a skunk
and the footprints that it left were
about 20 inches
long almost two feet
uh you know so somebody came out to
their house and like looked into it and
apparently um there were some other
kind of noises that they'd heard
subsequently and that they were kind of
like
a little bit uh
sort of damage on the side of the house
like it looked like somebody had been
like smacking the side of their house or
whatever so maybe the bigfoot had like
been hanging around there or whatever so
like i said that was one that happened
in 2011.
i bet virginia bigfoots are stuck up
yeah probably
[Laughter]
james snap just turned it 2011 what
state was that that was virginia that
one was in virginia
17 11 18 11 maybe even 1911 but man 2011
in virginia was just
esther says bigfoot got wild
i don't know it's you know i mean it's
not like virginia is the amazon basin
you know what i mean that's what i mean
it's kind of [ __ ] is this breeding
population come on that's the only thing
i kind of feel like and i'm not like
calling all these people's lot people
liars i don't think everybody's liars i
just think a lot of times
in the heat of the moment if you just
see something for a second
or
if you see something in the course of
like something upsetting like what the
[ __ ] is that noise or like somebody you
know or some kind of wailing or
something like that
then
maybe
you'll be like primed to see like kind
of a regular thing as maybe
um an unusual thing
yeah i don't you know i don't know
because the thing about it and this is
kind of true this is why i'm kind of
skeptical of a lot of different
paranormal things i'm gonna put my
skeptical hat on you're gonna put your
skeptical hat on yeah do you even have a
skeptical hand yeah well there's a wig
oh you have a skeptical wig yeah to
become extremely skeptical oh you oh
okay can you come straight today
today it's the skeptical way
and very analytical
and intellectual and extremely white
you have to have and we've got tilly in
the audience she always makes you feel
more caucasian
so
here i am i'm going to sit here and tell
you that
[ __ ] man what the [ __ ] is up with this
you need a barrette yeah yeah
trying to get old
all right there you go
all right it's gonna it's gonna fall
let's ponder this let's
[Laughter]
tila says do we know which state has the
most sightings yeah i think it's
probably washington state or oregon uh
western canada also has a lot washington
state would make sense i mean that's a
big force northern california there's a
lot of northern yeah and then that's
here in nevada
yeah
because i mean that is like a vast
wilderness area where a lot of people
don't live it's just not as remote as it
was a hundred years ago
even in the 70s and 80s when i was a kid
it was more remote and like i said this
is before the advent of really good spy
satellites they can pick up a man on
thermal imaging in the lifetime
and i know them [ __ ]
are like hey man you know what
let's see if there's a bigfoot
and they're [ __ ] up there in norad or
whatever they get the up link to the
satellite up i'm gonna go i mean you
know that somebody like when they're on
their break or something right they'll
just be like they're looking down in
there and they go that's deer that's
that's moose you know that's caribou
there's bear
keep looking you know like that you know
they keep checking back over there and
they're going nah because that's what
i'd be doing right i mean just if i
didn't have anything else to do at that
moment it's like hey let's look for a
bigfoot right and if they saw it they
would go there's a [ __ ] bigfoot and
then they would [ __ ] get the gps
coordinates and they'd [ __ ] go down
there or send somebody down there
and get to go get it to go kill one
i mean i would really like it if there
was big feets but um
big feeds but
i don't know i just think if there were
big feats i think they would have found
them by now yeah imagine if you could
capture one you could sell it how much
money would it be worth of course well
some people have tried to do that we'll
talk about that a little bit later like
some of the hoaxes and stuff yes but
because he wouldn't fall under he
wouldn't fall in the laws of dealing
with a human being
see it wouldn't be a human
so that means you could hunt it and
capture it just like an animal and sell
it well do you know that some states i
think new york state even has like a law
in the book so i'm sure it was like that
bigfoot if there was a bigfoot it would
be an endangered species so you aren't
allowed to shoot them right okay so but
you know all states are different like
and i don't know how much of like a joke
that was
like when they put the law on that but
they're saying hey if that was a real
thing it would probably be an endangered
species which it probably would uh so
they're like please don't shoot them you
know what i mean just like for a long
time in florida i don't know if you guys
knew this but for a long time in florida
alligators were endangered species
so you weren't allowed to shoot them for
a long time but now they're like kind of
proliferating so they're like okay shoot
them all you want well you're not
allowed to shoot them all you want but
you can shoot like a certain amount he
says that some are saying that they come
from another dimension well the reason
why they're saying that's because
there's a lack of footprints so you got
to explain why there's no footprint yeah
there is like a subset of bigfoot uh you
know lore that says that they're
inter-dimensional beings or they're
something to do with extraterrestrials
which is like that i don't know that
just to me seems like i don't know if
gilding the lily would be the be the
right term for that but it just really
does kind of seem like
you know it'd be cool enough if there
was like some unknown hominid that had
been like living out in the woods all
this time it's like why you gotta like
bring you up it's i kind of feel like
sometimes there's some like sub segment
of
paranormal the paranormal subculture
that just wants all of the paranormal
things to be like all in one they want
to make like a like an extended universe
like the mcu but with all the paranormal
things yeah like in one thing and it's
like all explained by one thing i guess
because it would simplify it maybe so i
do kind of feel like there's oh they
came here on ufos or they're coming
they're popping in and out of other
dimensions and that's why we're not
finding any dead ones that's why we're
not finding any poop that's why we're
not finding any blah blah blah yeah deal
that goes oh yeah i like the footprints
then grandpa goes yeah no lack of huge
bones
so you describe it away by saying well
they're coming from another dimension
it's a spiritual bigfoot
summoned by indian spirits near this
indian spirit indian spirit realm which
actually
that would actually come closer to a lot
of the native american lore that
i heard just on the periphery
that things like
skokum
weren't really physical beings anymore
they were more like spirits
you know what i mean yeah kind of like
they're kind of like the thunderbird and
the rain bird
they don't necessarily they're not
necessarily
physical creatures they're they're
they're
like like talking about angels
you know yeah and that
skoka might be like a spiritual wide
wild man
well it could also kind of be a
variation on a wendigo or a windmill
yeah it's not something you would expect
to see in a
some of the stories kind of
from what i from what i was told
some of the stories actually are
describing a spiritual creature
something that is like a like a ghost
or a nature spirit
like that yeah
and it could be that it might have been
based on something that existed a long
time ago
yeah i mean in a problem because the way
that people describe sasquatches sounds
very much like some other homicide
that did exist right um just not maybe
yeah just not here right and not now
so therefore the legend changes to well
well he's spiritual now
he lives on in our memories he's in the
spirit world now watching over us
which makes more sense right that makes
it and then that would even probably
because indians would have been in this
in the you know not ancient times but in
the 1700s 1800s
1600s i think i think the legends are at
the stories as far as white historians
would would know it they're hearing
these stories in the 1800s i don't think
there's any mention of them in the 1700s
and they may this those indian stories
might be from the 1800s
indian culture was not static it was
constantly evolving
so they may have come up with that in
the 1800s and told white people about it
and um
indians of the 1800s would have would
have been like well if skokam is a
physical creature why why can't we see
his footprints why isn't he hunting why
aren't we seeing him
well he's a spirit and that would
explain it to an indian
yeah like okay which is the same thing
as a person today going well he's from
another dimension that's why we're not
seeing these
it's the same argument it's just
different people giving that same
explanation of why
you don't find footprints why aren't you
finding the bones why aren't you seeing
them why aren't they migrating
why why do you see them down there
competing with the bears for fish
there has to be an explosion because
they gotta be eating something they're
spiritual they're from another dimension
same [ __ ] although how awesome would it
be i'm not sure if you'd be awesome or
terrifying or maybe a little bit of both
if i went out in the driveway one day
and saw a bigfoot digging through our
garbage again wouldn't that be neat like
being spiritual and being from another
dimension is essentially really what
they're saying is this in an
old-fashioned way of saying that they're
extinct that's what they're that they're
in the past
which like i said that's not crazy at
all because there were hominids that
looked kind of like people described
it's something that
is something that is passed down to them
in their imaginations
stories or fears of something like this
an inherited fear
of a bigger
hairier version of a human that could
eat you and you had to watch out for it
and the fossil record shows those
giganopithicus
yeah that was a real thing
like i said they don't they don't know
if it ever existed in north america but
it for sure existed in asia and although
it may have started then yeah although
as far as i know the only fossils they
found of giganopathic
giganopithecus they're not actually
entirely sure whether it was bipedal or
quadrupedal um because they said all
they found so far was like teeth
mandibles that type of thing so
they so it could go either way it
wouldn't have mattered because the
gorilla isn't bipedal
but africans in the 1800s described him
as a hairy wild man yeah it didn't
matter that he didn't walk around on all
on two legs all the time it was still
recognized as a as a hairy man-like
creature so
you know homo earlier homo sapiens from
ten thousand years ago if they saw a
gigantic pithecus they just would have
said that's a big man
yeah then [ __ ] will eat you
and then maybe they did that yeah they
very well they have i mean
but yes that's the closest thing to a
sasquatch that
we know of gigantopithecus you guys can
google what it looks like
that's that's
that's that's evidently that's that's a
sasquatch
it's just that are the stories that
they're saying are they directly related
to that or something like that maybe
is a long time ago i mean yeah and like
i said is it i mean it's possible
that
you know they that there were still
giganopithecus around um you know when
the bering strait land bridge was there
and it came across in north america
that's possible sure maybe there were a
few of them around
here in the united states in the 15th
1600s just very very few maybe
yeah and that's totally where that story
could have come from because like i said
it's not that's why i'm not real
you know i i don't think bigfoots
necessarily exist anymore but i do think
that there was i mean obviously there
were something that looked like that and
maybe there
were things that looked like that um
you know around the same time that
humans were coming and then the stories
just got passed on and even though they
may not might not be around anymore
um that doesn't mean that that doesn't
refer to a real thing some people might
counter what i'm saying to us here is
as you know as late as the 15th or 1600s
we'd have fossils
my counter would be no you wouldn't
you don't have very many fossils of
anything well fossilization is a very
very very rare
and
it's hard for something to become a
fossil that's why there's so many gaps
in the fossil record record if something
like a gigantic pithicus died in the 15
16 1700's even going back
a thousand years couple thousand years
if they died on the north american
continent chances are they were
immediately eaten
there's nothing left yeah i mean you
throw a turkey out in the backyard you
come back out the next morning because
we did that [ __ ] at the farm
[ __ ] come back out next morning it's
gone you never seen it you [ __ ] not
even
not even shredded well and it's like not
even that there's some predators and
bugs and you know insects everything
like that but it's like not only that
but then the conditions have to be
exactly right
for something to be fossilized and that
doesn't happen right i mean considering
that it's actually amazing that we have
as many fossils as we do and that you
know the fossil record is as complete as
it is
you know
north america
it would have been very very rare
you're talking about a couple thousand
of them the chances at any one time a
couple thousand of them and annualized
over a couple thousand years very very
slim here
yeah
and like i said they're pretty sure that
gigantopithecus did exist in asia and
even so all they've found of it like i
said is some jaw bones and some teeth
and stuff like that they haven't found
any like leg bones or anything like that
so you know so like i said i'm i'm not
saying i just i don't think
i don't think that it's still around
here as a species but what here's an
idea
when the spaniards showed up in the
1500s in mexico they brought european
plagues with them which caused an
apocalypse that killed most of the
indians
that's the reason why there was
colonization in north america it didn't
have anything to do with aggressive
white men with their guns and defeating
the indians [ __ ] though guns were
white men at the time could not stand
side by side with the native population
back in those days they were far better
and better equipped to survive here in
in the new world they kicked ass on the
vikings and the viking kicked ass on
every europeans and the indians kicked
the vikings asses pretty easily
they were
they had the right equipment guns didn't
help
settlers indians laughed at guns until
the [ __ ] advent of the metallic
cartridge case when that's when it
became practical
it could be that the there may have been
australopithecus here which would have
been described as a bigfoot but maybe
they died in that pandemic because there
wouldn't have been many of them anyway
if it was hominid maybe they were also
susceptible to those kind of diseases
yeah that's you know
that's that's totally blind and that
would have just wiped them out if there
was only a couple thousand of them the
chances of an australopithecus surviving
that damn pandemic would be very slim
because they were probably susceptible
to [ __ ] like the same [ __ ] [ __ ] like
[ __ ]
smallpox
it makes sense i bet you i bet you even
a chimpanzee could probably catch
smallpox
well yeah like i said they're very very
genetically similar right what is it 98
90 45 so that could be that could be an
explanation why it's gone
and and it would still be remembered
because that wasn't very long ago
you could you could pass down legends
from the 1500s that's what i'm saying i
do kind of feel like
you know some i'm not saying all legends
have to have some kernel of truth but a
lot of them do
um it's just that a lot of them become
exaggerated over the years it's like you
know one time
great uncle earl saw you know a komodo
dragon and then suddenly like it got
bigger and bigger like every time they
retold it you know i mean it's that type
of thing like a game like a game of
telephone so i kind of feel like maybe
that's what we have going here but like
i said yeah i feel like a lot of the
[ __ ] about like people that said they've
seen sasquatch is is not crazy no one's
saying that they're seeing like a
20-foot tall [ __ ] giant or anything
like that i mean these are just big
ape men
which like i said they know that
something like that did exist at some
point in the past so
i don't know whether they're still
seeing them nowadays i don't know danny
rowling ghostface says just like they
got an organization for reporting ufo
sightings which is mufon pretty sure
they have an organization for reporting
bigfoot sightings yeah they do i was
just talking about that it's called the
bfro uh bigfoot field research
organization i think it's called uh they
have a website with like
where you can report sightings on there
and they will come out and like
investigate them and whatnot um you know
that's that's kind of their main one i
feel like uh dj maniac says jenny do you
look into the australian version the
yowie men yeah i did we talked about
that on our old cryptids show where we
were just kind of covering all the
cryptids yeah the australia also has its
version which is called the yowie
um which like i said you know the asia
has a bunch of different ones they got
yeti they got the
what is that one called the as
almas almost whatever that one's called
that's in russia or whatever somebody
was saying it was unlikely that
something like an 11 foot tall or nine
foot tall oregon tank could walk across
that land bridge dude
you had [ __ ] willie mammoth here
while they walked across that land
bridge yeah that's not that's not all
that
and the the climactic conditions were
were different and [ __ ] changed over
time we don't know all the details it
might have been warm periods where that
could have happened
it's just there's no telling
our knowledge of the that those times is
not complete
and the thing that clouds the waters a
lot on bigfoot [ __ ] is that
a lot of the [ __ ] was later found out to
be hoaxes or you know
just people making [ __ ] up
and it may not have been the
oscillopithecus
or gigantopithecus maybe it's just
something related to that or another
kind of hominid that's gone
and we know that the hominid fossil
record is super incomplete because the
pot the populations were always low
and which meant that it made
fossilization
unlikely because there wasn't enough of
them
and like i said even now it's been
fairly recently that they just found out
like all these other like kind of
hominid species that were going around
at the same time i mean that's like only
in the last couple decades they've come
up with that there may have been
something that was
pretty human and
from from a recent era that kana could
be described as a
a as a bigfoot and it may have not have
been a may have been another species but
another species of of man
maybe it was viable maybe you could
actually cross breed with it because it
wasn't as inhuman as you think it was
just a big guy
six feet tall plus which would seem huge
to a person from the times we're talking
about when most people were about five
one
it'd have been big if it was you know
six four and it was just hairy just a
hairy person
you know
that might be possible and we're talking
about
you know six thousand years ago five
thousand two thousand something like
that
yeah it's like i said to me this doesn't
seem
like i said i don't know people that are
seeing them nowadays like are actually
seeing them or if they're seeing
something else or whatever but
i'm not saying this is of all the you
know cryptids of all the paranormal type
subjects this is kind of one that seems
the most plausible to me even though i'm
not sure i buy it a hundred percent but
it's so plausible that people exaggerate
well that too and and worry about people
that are bigger than them and wilder
than them
well if a person is bigger than you and
wilder than you how do you express in
your story that that motherfucker's wild
he's not wearing any clothes
he's got hair all over him
he's wild even all over his back so it's
kind of a logical leap yeah
he's like an animal an animal man an
animal man is going to be hairy so it's
kind of like a
logical leap we'll see human animal
hybrids are like a pretty common
that's a pretty common like trope in
folklore like all around the world you
know and probably be a pretty common
fear you're walking yeah
you're walking around you're afraid of
getting robbed by somebody from another
tribe but then you take it one step
further he's not only from another tribe
he's slightly from another species he's
wild he's got [ __ ] hair like a damn
dog or a hair like a you know what i
mean all over his body like a wild
animal
what what
i gotta take
[Laughter]
yeah so
so like i said i this i wanted to
mention this because like i said we
brought up the you know the one in the
southeastern united states usually
called the skunk ape uh you know we've
had sightings of them down here uh they
have one in ohio called the grass man
you know i mentioned like the f i guess
called the falc monster in arkansas
which like i said you've seen the boggy
creek uh movies
that's uh charles b pierce that's uh
what those are about i wanted to like
ask anybody from virginia though because
apparently there's one in virginia which
is called
the wood booger it's called the wood
booger right
that's like so what is that all about
what is what is wood booger why is it
called that it's just like so if
anybody's from virginia just like let me
know if you've heard of that um honey
island swamp monster i think we talked
about that on our last cryptids show
but there's like a bunch of uh different
ones but they're all like essentially
like the same thing
um so i mentioned before how sometimes
people said they threw rocks um you know
found weird [ __ ] in the woods like um
big trees broken off or put in like
weird configurations or stuff that was
like really like too heavy for a person
to move like moving around in weird ways
um apparently there was one
i guess that was kind of like some other
instances where there were like some
deer skeletons that were like hung up in
trees or whatever and i guess they
thought like no people had been there um
also there was apparently this one group
of bigfoot researchers that said that
they had found a bunch of
sort of primate kind of nests like out
in these like remote woods and stuff so
maybe that's kind of going more into
maybe it's some kind of unknown primate
but the thing about it though is that
like it seems like a lot of the
sightings take place at night which is
unusual because if this is a primate
i'm pretty sure
that most primates at least kind of
great apes and stuff like that are
diurnal was just like much like humans
are um there are i think there are some
species of like lemurs which are like
you know
proto primates i guess you would call
them that are nocturnal but pretty much
all the great apes as far as i know all
the great apes are
diurnal so
if there is a sasquatch if it does exist
and it's nocturnal that would be very
unusual again
the eye shine would also be unusual
because no primates that they know of
have that um so like i said a lot of
people have reported like you know a
particular type of noise they make some
say they even like speak a language or
something that sounds like a language um
so there were some recordings made in
the early 1970s which i think somebody
brought up earlier um
that
i guess like some linguists had said
you know i i don't know how credible
this is but like some um linguists had
said that it kind of sounded like a a
language
um and they called these these were
supposedly recorded in the sierra nevada
mountains so they're called the sierra
sounds um and he had said that it
definitely is a language and it's not
human um and at least in his opinion it
couldn't have been faked like i said i
don't uh really know if that's
uh you know how credible that is but
that's just what that uh what he claimed
now also the dude from survivorman les
stroud
he has also said
that um when he was out filming some of
the survivorman shows that he actually
did hear something
that
he couldn't identify like as any species
that he knew of
um i don't think he outright said it was
a sasquatch but he was just saying that
it was like an animal type noise and he
didn't uh know what it was
so uh we were talking about before like
what
you know bigfoot's bigfeets uh would eat
if they indeed did exist
um
in like i don't know i feel like in the
pacific northwest like i said they would
probably be in direct competition with
bears black bears in particular
uh so you would kind of think that
they would be eating maybe have to eat
the same type of stuff like they'd have
to be omnivores um like i said eating
fish maybe even coming down like digging
through people's garbage like bears do
[ __ ] like that um
you know some of them i guess some
people have reported that they have also
been killing their livestock and [ __ ]
like that oh he's putting like another
well she's gonna spoil
[Laughter]
i didn't say anything
i didn't say anything
she took me to three different doors and
decided each one too hot
it's too hot this one let's go to the
other one uh it's too hot out it's like
it's like there's like each door out
leads to another she has to check she
has to check every single door to make
sure that all the outsides are all bad
are all bad and she's like okay [ __ ] it
no
and she uh she uh and then probably in
five minutes she'll forget yeah
i'm gonna i've turned the carnitas over
to turn that pork shoulder over now are
we gonna eat good are we gonna eat some
of that before we go out or why not
still got several hours on it that's all
right cooking is slow i didn't realize
we can get something else before i got
other stuff in here we eat yeah or we
can get something on the way over
or we can get some on the way back like
at ihop or something yeah we're trying
to do that last time right now
well i wasn't
well because we had eaten a little bit
of cake and it really it kind of made me
feel kind of unwell and
yeah and i was just like i don't feel
like i can eat anything uh because i'll
probably barf and i'm pretty sure i told
you that okay yeah cause remember we had
cake because it was big tom's birthday
yeah and i couldn't even eat that i eat
like three or four bites of cake and i'm
just like yeah i don't feel too good
and i wasn't even wearing a corset that
night i don't know what my problem was
but uh yeah i think it was because i you
know kind of dry i didn't drink a [ __ ]
ton but i drank a lot but it's like i
didn't eat a lot so i didn't i felt kind
of ill so tiva split okay everybody said
they missed tina yeah she had to go uh
she was going out to dinner or something
like that yeah yeah
so so like i said i do kind of feel like
if this does exist then it's probably
like it would have to be an omnivore
right i mean they would just have to eat
whatever whatever it was around like
nuts fish they had to be like a bear
yeah like daily or kill you know like i
said bears around here like they'll dig
through your garbage or open your fridge
if you leave your garage open if you
have a fridge in your garage i have to
be an omnivorous kind of like a um
not a predator but what i forgot what
you call it
uh omnivore
no
an omnivorous um
what do you call the [ __ ] thing
i don't i don't know what you're getting
at it's just something that um takes
advantage of other things that are
around it i'm trying to remember the
term the terminology for it it's uh not
a scavenger bus uh an opportunist yeah
an opportunist a food operator so it can
hunt a little bit like it can scavenge
and then it contracts things down and
it'll eat a little bit of carry and you
know that's
it'll steal from other animals bears
will do all that they'll sit around and
eat
berries and then it'll fish they're just
kind of an opportunist
well that's why i mean that's why where
we live you have to have your garbage
cans have to be bear safe garbage cans
they even the county came around and
gave everyone a bear safeguard with the
little trigger thing on it so bears
can't open it most you're more
intelligent more flexible creatures that
are survivable are survivable or like
that because they're they're kind of
like a jack of all trades they can do a
little bit of everything and that's what
really what you need to survive well yes
you become too specialized you're not
generalized enough you're real
specialized as soon as the habitat
changes you're gone well bears are kind
of like people they'll just eat anything
yeah whatever's laying around right
like old pizza okay well that's why
people survived yeah but you know
something like a koala will never choose
poor koalas koala would never survive in
a changing environment i mean it can
only pretty much eat eucalyptus leaves
yeah that's about it
and they beg and cry
cry baby they're so cute though i kind
of feel like that's their superpower is
their cuteness because then they can get
humans to help them hey yeah they'll go
to humans for help
a wild animal that'll go up to human and
just start crying
he took me out of the tree look how cute
it is they knock each other out of the
damn trees
you want us to like koalas you know
something gross they do it's like so
they eat the eucalyptus and then they
poop it out and then the babies have to
like eat the poop yeah
yeah they're very dumb too they're
they're evidently of extreme
creatures they can't help it very low
intelligence just little eucalyptus
eaters you can't help it yeah i mean
eucalyptus aren't gonna like [ __ ]
outsmart them so it's like they don't
have to be super real slow
but like i said they're not a generalist
they're very specialized they can only
do one thing and when that's gone
they're gone
yeah
i know that's like really sad and most
animals are actually kind of like not
most or a lot of animals are like that
real special well they kind of like yeah
evolved in a real specialized um you
know what i hate to say but like even
cats like big cats and stuff like that
is pretty much they can't yeah they just
eat meat yeah that's it yep they don't
you know they're not really supposed to
eat anything other than that
yeah they're they can't change their
ways no times are hard they starve yeah
which is like like i said that's kind of
[ __ ] sasquatches apparently and if they
just eat anything then you'll probably
be all right because
you know you can just like live on
whatever same with a [ __ ] raccoons just
survive anything
yeah raccoons will definitely eat
anything that's they don't call it a
trash panda for nothing yeah
yeah so uh i think i brought up earlier
incident uh supposed incident that
happened back in 1924 this was like
reported in newspaper so they called it
the battle of ape canyon
and this was supposedly
uh there was a bunch of miners that were
working in this area
uh i think it was in california or
oregon or somewhere like that
and apparently these miners all said
that they got um that a bunch of like a
bunch of hairy ape dudes were like
throwing
rocks onto the roof of their cabin from
a cliff
um and they were apparently do a cabin
from a cliff
um and they were apparently doing this
in retaliation because one of the miners
drew it
yeah it says okay reconnection
successful
yep yeah
yeah we got our my obs like disconnected
but it supposedly came back on so it
should be it's not the same laptop so we
shouldn't have this problem that was
that was probably our service it might
have been yeah because we really haven't
had that much problem since we got this
new since we got this new laptop yeah um
you know what i mean like because
remember but the one before like we had
it did it all the time that was a memory
problem
it was i haven't really had uh too much
trouble since it's just every now and
then i get yeah so this is this laptop's
a lot more powerful than our old one
yeah
um
also in 1924
there was a dude he was canadian and his
name was albert ostman
uh he was a prospector now he said that
he got you're gonna love this he said
that he got abducted by a bigfoot yeah
there was a lot of these kinds of and
that he was like he was held prisoner
there with like um with the fam with the
bigfoot family
and that he was there for six days this
was in british columbia
um
let me top your drink off yeah on a half
or a full one just give me a half one
okay because it's like that's i mean
it's good it's like but it's very lemony
so it's like real acidic yeah and you
know like i said i've i've eaten very
little today so it's like i had like a
little tiny sandwich and that's it
that's all no i think i had some
cinnamon toast like at seven o'clock
this morning and then i had like a
little tiny sandwich with a little bit
of pork and pickles on it and that's all
and that was like hours and hours ago so
it's like i don't want to drink too much
because i'll be like oh i'm gonna puke
but yeah so
can you imagine
for some reason like when i read this
account i was thinking of the
um i don't know why i just thought of
the star wars
holiday special
with all the wookiees
because i just kind of thought but that
would like but they didn't do anything
bad to him so i don't really know like
so they just kidnapped him just because
they thought he was neat and they just
wanted to like like
it was like finding a toy
like in the woods or something he's like
oh let's take this home and like took it
back because he said they didn't do
anything to him and he was there for
like six days and they just thought he
was like funny so
i don't know that story just like amuses
the [ __ ] out of me i don't know why
like i said i just thought of like
this little white dude like sitting
there
with a bunch of wookies like poking at
him and stuff that's kind of what i
thought of i don't know why so um so
here's one that happened in 1971 and
this was actually
it's just got a lot of ice in it oh okay
thanks this one actually happened in uh
falc or whatever arkansas so like i said
this would be like your boggy creek
creature uh type thing
so yeah oh she did yeah she saw a gun
she went right to the [ __ ] door right
i'm sick of this [ __ ] no i can't believe
it anymore i've been sleeping here all
day
so she just went out to like the front
door
okay
well we'll just you know as soon as it
shows that we're going like bring her in
get her little like uh clothes off yeah
we don't have that much go
not really like i said i wanted to talk
like about a couple of the uh you know
the the hoaxes and stuff but the stream
seems to be running fine it's running
fine here yeah i mean like i said it did
seem to come back on so we'll see so
um
so yeah this
i kind of feel like um
there haven't been even though there's
one in falco arkansas where uh
apparently a
uh sasquatch or you know whatever the
boggy creek creature you ever want to
call it um kind of reached in the window
like started grabbing at people
but
i guess that there haven't really been
any real super credible reports of like
a bigfoot killing anybody although i
mentioned earlier
that if you have hulu there's a series
on their mini series rather it's like
it's three episodes called sasquatch and
the first episode is kind of about
it is kind of more sasquatchy bigfooty
than the other [ __ ] but it's kind of
more about the drug trade in the early
night like in the 80s and the early 90s
like everybody growing weed like up in
the emerald triangle like in northern
california and how there was this like
crazy murder of like three dudes and
some people were attributing it to a
sasquatch and so like the guy that was
investigate was going around and he was
talking to some
you know bigfoot people that were saying
um you know that some of them said oh
you know there's no reports of bigfoot's
killing anybody and then some of them
said oh they totally do kill people and
like tear their arms and heads off and
blah blah blah so there was kind of so i
feel like there's kind of like depending
on
where like what angle you're coming at
it from
uh you know
do they are they aggressive do they kill
people
i kind of feel like it's not really that
even like going back to the 70s with all
the in search of and all the [ __ ] they
used to talk about because i feel like
bigfoot lore was like real big in the
70s too and it feels like lately it's
kind of made a resurgence and i feel
like
the resurgence that it's had lately is
more focusing on bigfoot being
violent
whereas i feel like the ones in the 70s
were not i never really felt
the ones in the 70s i don't remember
ever hearing about um people being
attacked by big feet but bigfoot
um but lately i've seen that more like
whether it's in a fictional thing or
whether it's like reporting
i do kind of feel like people are
reporting that they're more like
aggressive now and i don't know if
that's just like a cultural change
i kind of feel like that's probably why
because in the 70s everyone was just
kind of like they just saw it like
walking around
70s of culture especially out in the
sierra nevadas you know me i was growing
up in california i was there during the
70s
went up to sequoia and
redwood forest
and um
that whole
up in the mountains country scene which
was that's where you're going to get
bigfoot sides
was real [ __ ] john denvery smoking
pot real kind of hippie-ish but i kind
of kind of the cooler version of hippie
we're not talking about the hate ashbury
hippies these are more like the [ __ ]
ranger hippies almost kind of like
people that would
like tolkien books and listen to led
zeppelin and [ __ ] well these were kind
of like and they they talked about this
on the sasquatch show too it's like
these were kind of like back to the land
hippies they just wanted to kind of go
live out in the wilderness jeremiah
johnson
and then started growing pot just like
as a way to make money right
and they they weren't really free
loaders you're talking about people who
are trying to live like uh because you
know the ashbury hippies were junkies
they were just [ __ ] freeloaders you
know girls giving ahead to get some get
drugs and [ __ ] they didn't really have
jobs or anything but up there in the
mountains them trying to do that they
did have jobs they were you know
building log cabins and although you
know you had to own land a lot of them
became um
uh forest rangers and stuff
so it was a very different they were
kind of like uh
really much like uh trying to bring back
kind of like a native american type
lifestyle
and sasquatch fit in right in with that
yeah okay
so their sasquatch would have been a
peaceful satisfaction sasquatch or at
least one that was just like a part of
nature part of nature
like it like man
you don't [ __ ] with him and he don't
[ __ ] with you man it's a respect you
know what i mean yeah you respect his
land and he respects you to be that kind
of story stories like that
which
fits right in with the culture of that
time i was there it was cool time
actually it was very cool
hey man it's okay take your clothes off
baby every cut
go down to lake clark oh and there's
nothing but just teenage girls of
[ __ ] all ages with adults and [ __ ]
[ __ ] all nudism they just take off to
take their clothes off
smooth sunbathing
and you'd have and it wasn't perverted
it wasn't seen it wasn't considered like
erotic or anything it was just
it was just like a back to nature type
thing i was tripping i was like god damn
these girls are [ __ ] cute i'd be like
12 11 yeah i was like you were a kid too
so it wasn't like you were older and you
were like you're not a teenage girl
no no i was like 10 11 12.
[Laughter]
now the young ones didn't really impress
me i was looking at the [ __ ] like 17
16
to 20 year olds you know ones that were
stacked they're like oh gosh you're
looking good i better jump in this water
before i rock up
sucker funny you know you're smoking pot
[ __ ] passing [ __ ] and the park
rangers are there [ __ ] [ __ ]
playing guitar and [ __ ] selling wheat
yeah yeah well like part rangers sold
wade back well like i said if you
watched um if you watched the sasquatch
mini series on hulu the first episode
which is kind of more about the
sasquatch legend a little bit um they do
kind of go into the history of like all
the hippies that
went into like northern california and
wanted to live off the grid and would go
and like build cabins in these remote
wilderness and then they said well
you know they were growing their own
food and stuff like that but they needed
a cash crop so that's why a lot of them
started growing pot back in the 70s when
it was illegal
and um as time went on like there was
such competition like for the money and
everything in there that they all
started like you know carrying guns and
doing [ __ ] like that because you didn't
want people stealing your [ __ ] you know
because and even to this day i believe
it's like i'm not really i'm not a big
weed person but a lot of people said
like humboldt county like northern
california that's like the best weed in
the world like a lot of people say
um just because the uh you know the the
climate there is like perfect for
growing pot uh so yeah so they go a lot
into that which actually i thought was
even though i'm not a big weed person i
thought was like actually really
interesting what do you do no i had i
had to reset it no i'm worried about it
she's wearing what i'm doing well it's
like well sometimes i'm talking and then
all of a sudden what are you talking i
hear this noise that was you that noise
was your voice well i know but it's like
i don't want my own voice coming back at
me
captain said women have big sasquatch
butchers back then
not all of them but yeah
david june you know the more the show
goes on the more i'm convinced big feet
are the stinky awkward byproducts of
humans and grace
i mean sure
why not like i said i don't i don't i
don't know i don't i don't like the idea
of the of big feats and the aliens like
being
i don't know i said keep them keep those
two things separate
i don't know what those two things have
to do with each other like not really
anything well
you know when you were out camping at
the sequoia they had a lot to do with
each other because people were [ __ ]
[ __ ] at night around that campfire
looking up at the stars smoking all the
weird [ __ ] that they were around
playing guitar and [ __ ] putting john
denver what if
sasquatch was an alien
well you might worry
you might think the sasquatch might be
watching you from the
from the shadows you know i mean the
[ __ ] these big redwood trees
everywhere and then you're looking up
squatching the shadows and then just a
few minutes yeah and then just a few
minutes later you're looking up they got
bg's playing on the [ __ ] right you're
looking at you know some kind of woman
to me
[Laughter]
and you're looking up you know mother
and a woman
and like you hear your [ __ ] 17 year
old aunt making out with some dude
[ __ ] in the damn what you call it the
[ __ ] sleeping bag two sleeping bags
over you know like what's all that noise
you know
then you're like looking up the stars
and you [ __ ] see
shooting star go by you know and [ __ ]
you go oh man that was a ufo you know
what if that was the aliens flying
saucer so you your mind could
run away with you
okay because so everybody's smoking this
really good weed in humboldt county yeah
uh you know and maybe there's a squatch
out there looking at you which like i
said plausible um and then you suddenly
see something that kind of looks like a
ufo and it's just kind of like all one
yeah it's all one thing man me i was a
kid i was just happy to be there
you know all this cool [ __ ] going on did
they give you any pot no no huh they
hogged it all for themselves yeah yeah
they weren't that they weren't that they
weren't they weren't that freaky
they're like no we're not giving that to
the little kid no they wouldn't give it
to you they wouldn't give it to like a
12 year old
but you could drink wine
but that's not weird though like
europeans do that's just what it was
that's nice that's what it was in
california back then well i mean when i
was a kid they didn't really i mean you
know when i thought you're gonna be
driving right yeah i mean when i was a
kid they wouldn't let the kid get drunk
obviously but they're just kind of like
oh you know let's they'd give you a sip
of beer like just to be funny or
something yeah i drink those wine
coolers
yeah i had wine 70s wine coolers was
like
annie green springs [ __ ] or or
boone's farm [ __ ] cheap wine i feel
like annie green springs was even like
on the on a lower tier than boone's farm
it came in a big ass jug yeah well yeah
that's what i mean it was like even
cheaper
a couple bucks and you mixed it 50 50
was with seven up and that was the
original wine cooler and that was just
[ __ ] that girls would make but they give
it to kids too you know for like a
special treat yeah drinking [ __ ] 24 7.
give them enough and like the kids will
be quiet all night yeah
you know drink it slow they're like that
you know but you know it's just the way
that this society was very different
back then
pre-emulsion when i was a kid like that
[ __ ] cough medicine just now i
thought it tasted good would that have
been acceptable in the bible built in
the 70s [ __ ] no but this was california
it was very different i've been i was in
both of them yeah but no it was very
difficult like i said i grew up in like
kind of rednecky florida so it's kind of
like it was kind of the same thing with
us they kind of like let kids run around
in mud puddles and it's like hey how's
it going here have a bear when you hear
about how cool california was and you
know and go west and all this kind of
[ __ ] and all these songs and what they
were talking about how great california
is because of that they're talking about
that era
60s and 70s the rest of the united
states was kind of pretty uptight
it's not it's nowhere near as bad as it
was now uh
nowhere near as bad as it used to be
yeah they were talking about like my
grandmother's version of the south yeah
that was pretty [ __ ] up dry counties
and [ __ ] but that's all gone
those people are all although there are
still dry counties nowadays they don't
matter though there's nothing there well
yeah there's nothing
yeah i'm just saying that that does
still exist yeah there's nothing there
except religious cults that own those
areas of southern baptists and even if
you live there and you want liquor all
you do is just drive over the county
line and drive and then
yeah they do that to keep outsiders out
they do not want
they do not they're not trying to be hip
they want you to stay the [ __ ] away from
them
[Laughter]
but they leave there all the time
to go other places and their children
leave and don't come back for the most
part except for family
visits that that culture is just fading
well it's like who the hell wants to
hang around people like that i mean
there's nothing there that's what i mean
there's nothing there this is like no
fun at all no and there aren't even jobs
there most of the people are gone the
people who
most of the people from those areas are
gone the ones that are there they're on
welfare
yeah yeah
danny rowling goes faces you mean to
tell me fuzzy naval wine coolers aren't
manly
hey i'll drink them i'm just i'm not
manly but you know what i mean we get
every now and then
we kind of get a wild hair like when
we're at sam's and we'll get like that a
case of those
what are they they're not um
what are those wine coolers what's the
is it seagram's are they secrets
where they have like and it's like four
different flavors there's like a water
but they all have like cutesy names like
watermelon wiggle or sometimes it's not
called that but it's like i don't
remember what it is and i think there's
a fuzzy navel in there and then there's
a peach that's a peach something or
other there's a watermelon with a
strawberry one and i can't remember what
the other one the other one's blue what
the [ __ ] the other one i don't
remember but uh those are actually
pretty good but honestly i could drink
probably the whole case of those
and not
because man sometimes like when we've
got a case of them like we'll sit around
and just drink four or five of them and
it's like it's just like drinking soda
raptors talking about dry counties in
kentucky yeah they have them but they're
jokes yeah i think there's some in
florida too yeah they're jokes
it was done by
peop those those laws were made by
people that are long dead
uh the people that are there now are
mostly retired people
who
they're living off of some kind of
retirement or people that are on welfare
oh there's the population density is
very low
it's not that there's no booze there
it's just you can't buy any and there's
no there's no bars
they have liquor it's in their houses
and they just go to another county and
get it it's you know 15 minutes yeah
it's not like illegal to go to another
county and buy it and have a house yeah
which like i said it's dumb because it's
just like a loophole and
it was not preventing [ __ ] it was
because those counties got taken over by
some kind of church
a long time ago and they put that in
there to keep the riff raff out
well and also i kind of feel like
there's an element of well we're not
having any fun in life so no one else
should either
me
[Laughter]
i think i think what it was is there it
was virtue signaling
our church doesn't
agree doesn't agree with drunkenness so
we can't have that
in this county because our church
dominates this county but then the same
people that passed that law are at home
having a drink because they just went
over to the other county got it
well yeah it's virtue signaling and then
they go back to church and go see we got
rid of the evil from our from our uh
county but most of that was my
grandparents generation
they're not doing that
they felt like they were trying to pull
that when i was growing up they were
trying to pull that in daytona where not
so much bars because like that that ship
has sailed but uh in daytona because
we're one of the spring break capitals
yet but they were trying to in it at
least within the city limits they were
like oh we don't want tattoo parlors we
don't want this that and the other thing
uh because yeah because that so they
were trying to do that kind of trashy
and they succeeded for a little while
but at this point yeah they died they
were just kind of like yeah yeah it's
not progress like people think well we
did it we fought them with progress no
they died yeah that's what always
happens
their values were different they did
that's trashy we don't want that trashy
stuff this is a nice neighborhood
we don't want you know porn behind the
counter at 7-eleven that's trashy it all
had to do with appearances
yeah they're they're really and the
thing about people like that is they're
always doing way more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
than normal people like yeah they're
doing it they did all that [ __ ] to
impress other people they went to church
with yeah so see how great i am because
why would you worry about it unless you
were doing like some way worse [ __ ] and
you were trying to like cover for
something yeah that's what i figured see
how holy i am i got alcohol abandoned
this county made sure that it was bad
you know praise the lord you're so great
and then okay church is over and they go
to the other counties go have a drink go
buy some [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever they did
buy some porn and vibrators and
nipple clamps it was all fake that was
fake
and everybody i knew from little like
little heidelberg and all these [ __ ]
bible thumpers from my grand uh mother's
generation that was in the heidelberg
laurel area
um they were all fake they're neurotic
old women
really
with empty nest syndrome we're doing
that or um
the worst ones are the ones that never
married never had kids they were the
most holy
and uh their whole thing was the virtue
signal in church and to make sure
everybody obeyed
and nobody could stand them even the
people that were in church there who
didn't stay well yeah there was a time
in which if you didn't go to church they
looked at you sideways
yeah like you don't go yeah i remember
that i mean they didn't care what your
last name was what race you were the
first question they'd ask or where you
from they would ask you what church you
went to
because all the churches were
hated each other it was ridiculous
it is right you go to that church
that was just part of your
social standing but those people
progress did not happen people they got
people liking i don't know
boston university well we progressed for
no they didn't those people just died
well that's a type of progress it's a
type of progress but it didn't have
anything to do with what happened
anywhere else they died and they and uh
they weren't they were replaced with
people that didn't believe in that [ __ ]
yeah and they didn't believe it because
kind of progress yeah and they didn't
believe in it because they were the kids
that had to [ __ ] put up with that
they had to put up with it and it didn't
have anything to do with their
educations or anything to do with the
[ __ ] school system or nothing to do
they were just like you never really go
are in for the [ __ ] that your parents
were into and definitely the [ __ ] your
grandparents were into was wasn't cool
definitely that wasn't cool you know
so it just changed because of that and
those people weren't cool
wouldn't have been my grandparents
generation wouldn't have been cool about
my great great grandparents they would
have said they were teetotaling [ __ ]
[ __ ]
probably that's what they would have
said yeah because the south
traditionally was [ __ ] wild real wild
yeah
so and and they didn't like that
temperance movement you know where you
where you were trying to abolish
liquor and [ __ ]
yeah you had old church women did that
and everybody in the south became
bootleggers
like i said i don't mind having things
about yeah people shouldn't be driving
on that [ __ ] and you know and [ __ ] like
that but it's like i don't back in those
days it didn't matter because you the
roads weren't paved and you just had
model a's model t's they couldn't go
fast anyway that's true you're basically
driving a tractor on a dirt road yes
usually through most of it
you're going 20 miles an hour you could
be [ __ ] loaded it wouldn't make any
difference yeah i'm you know i'm just
saying as long as there's like a few
safeguards in place i don't really have
and honestly and i've said on the show
before i don't really have a problem
with them legalizing
all drugs to be honest that's on you if
you take that [ __ ] um yeah as long as
you're an adult i don't think they
should be selling it to kids or anything
like that but it's like as long as
you're an adult you know what you're
doing and the quality isn't they're not
and like i said you're not driving
around
if you had good quality drugs you
wouldn't have to be endangering other
people then if you had good quality
drugs they would be safer because the
quality control would be there and then
you wouldn't have poor people [ __ ]
lowering themselves doing [ __ ] like
flakka which is [ __ ] garbage that'll
kill you that's what i mean i would
rather you're gonna do drugs which
people have been doing drugs since the
beginning of humans okay it's just this
is something we do it's i'm not passing
judgment on it it's not part of that
it's just
as part of the original human rights of
america was called the right to bliss
yeah and they were taking morphine and
doing opium and [ __ ]
cocaine and yeah people got addicted but
other people knew about it they were
like yeah you don't want to that'll
that's habit forming you know
but people were free to choose
you know people knew that that [ __ ] was
habit for me i mean yeah to an extent as
long as you know what you're getting
into and you're an adult you're
consenting i don't really have a problem
with it like i said as long as you're
not endangering other people yeah um you
know driving or
you know just let's do this [ __ ] in the
house full of children yeah that's not
good but um other than that i i don't
really have a problem with it yeah
grandpa's brought up a good one a four
pack of bartles and james in 87 with
your girlfriend at fort george drive in
magic in the back seat was certain
that's right
yeah
well you got you got the wine coolers
back in the day for the girls because
that's what they demanded back in the
80s they wouldn't drink anything other
than that but i remember [ __ ] in 87
me mike kowalski and steve we would
drink southern comfort
we liked that one for some reason i
don't know why because you could drink
it straight probably yeah you could
drink it straight it's a terrible
[ __ ] headache it would i used to i
drank it in coffee sometimes yeah it's
pretty good in coffee although jamison's
a little bit better
yeah for a little morning pick-me-up
i don't really do that anymore but i did
that when i was younger
yes sandra
we'll get you some southern comfort
that's the jagermeister of america
it's like
candied whiskey it's the only way i can
it's like a whiskey liqueur kind of like
dram bowie the cheaper yeah
yeah yeah
uh so yeah so what are we talking about
okay so let's get back to my bigfoot
let's get back to bigfoot yeah and we
want to kind of [ __ ]
try to end this in about a half hour
possible
yeah okay yeah uh yeah i can do that
like well because we brought up some
[ __ ] before about
how i kind of feel like i don't i don't
know if this is the case but i do kind
of feel like a lot of cases of
maybe bigfoot sightings are probably
black bears
yeah
just in the sense that a black bear
um standing on two legs
would
kind of be approximately the same size
uh you know shape behavior
as what they're reporting as a sasquatch
i'm not saying all of them are
i'm just saying um you know because i
know that some people that are like
hunters and have seen black bears and
blah blah you know have seen have
reported seeing sasquatch so i'm not
calling them liars i'm just saying that
probably the majority of them are
probably black bears i i would think um
but so let's kind of talk about
some people that because remember i
brought this up before
so just a pro tip
don't
put on
a sasquatch costume
and go out in the woods trying to make a
youtube video like hoaxing it because
you're likely to get shot there's a
pretty good chance that you might get
shot
just say just saying i'm just looking
out for everybody dead sasquatch would
be worth a lot of money i mean yes
so
two 2013
there was a dude he was a 21 year old
guy in oklahoma
and uh he was arrested
after
uh
this actually nobody was dressed like
bigfoot but there him and a bunch of his
friends were out in the woods looking
for bigfoot and apparently he mistook
his friend for a big or so he said and
shot him in the back i don't think the
dude died
but
i don't know if he just wanted to kill
that friend and that was like the story
that he came up with oh i thought he was
a sasquatch so i shot it
but that's uh so that kind of happened
there
uh there was another case in 2017 where
there was a dude he was kind of one of
those like shaman [ __ ] it's
like wearing animal furs all the time so
he was in north carolina like you know
communing with nature like out in the
forest and um he didn't get shot at but
like a bunch of people reported a
sasquatch like out in the woods and it
was just this dude walking around see
here's something else somebody's going
what could somebody mentioned wait a
minute they're reporting black bears all
over the world you have to understand
that you're dealing with a with
statistical phenomena all right you have
this dude who's in
furs being a shaman out in the woods
somebody sees that and go that
[ __ ] looks like a sasquatch and
then his buddy goes yeah call it in
call it
all right i see a sasquatch and they
know it's not a sasquatch that might
account for some of them and then
somebody else sees a bear but it's
standing upright a bear looks pretty
humanoid in their actions and and when
they're walking on their back
legs when you see them
if it's behind a bunch of trees it's
really kind of veiled you can't see all
of it at once you might think you're
seeing a furry man walking away for a
few seconds
and then you report that as a [ __ ]
sasquatch it's a bunch of little things
that all kind of add up yeah to a
phenomenon and they say well yeah but in
other countries bears are everywhere
bears are [ __ ] everywhere bears are
in china
okay so yeah
yeah it could be bears a lot of it
but a lot of it just could be people
hoaxing or misidentification or they see
something and they know that that's a
damp bear on its back legs or they know
that that's a bear and they go ma'am
i'll call that in as a bigfoot because
that was kind of like a bigfoot
bears have big feet right yeah it's like
a bigfoot
you know it'll be everybody'll love it
i'm just gonna say it's a bigfoot
okay well
here near where we lived all right
there's a train track and i saw in local
print media online
that
the train conductors
as they went through this neighborhood
it was it was that it was actually
heathrow
saw what they described as a large but
bipedal possibly a gorilla
all right oh i remember that remember
when that happened yeah yeah yeah it was
not a gorilla it was a bear yeah i saw
that same bear because they they gave
the day
and that in that area there was a big
[ __ ] bear walking around he crossed
the road right in front of me
it was that bear
that's what he saw i mean we've see we
see bears often enough around here that
you can identify different bears yeah
yeah you know what i mean because yeah
those jokers [ __ ] reported it as a
gorilla
they said they only saw it briefly
yeah you know
and it was a bear yeah
like i said you'd think they would know
that because there's bears all over this
one big old beer yeah it was the size of
a gorilla but it was it was a bear yeah
i've seen ones just walking around the
[ __ ] neighborhood in the middle of
the day that are as big as a gorilla
easily yeah or bigger and you know
there's no telling who these guys
working on this train where they're from
you know what i mean you don't know how
old they are they may not have been on a
job very long they might have been from
up north or something and maybe they're
just maybe the first time they've seen a
bear
it was fast and maybe they just didn't
think bears existed in florida sunny
florida this is a tropics there's no
bears here [ __ ] this place is over
[ __ ] flows hairs everywhere yeah
especially around here i've seen i've
never seen as many bears as i've seen
since i've moved here little swole has a
damn relationship with like about about
about eight of them that come in the
back of that house he was living
remember that yeah he says man there are
like eight of them i'm getting a
relationship with
bears are gonna [ __ ] bite you dude
stop [ __ ] with those bears
yeah you might keep feeding them and
stuff you know they tell you not to do
that it's it's not the good idea they're
not super aggressive but they remember
you know where you live they'll come
into your house because you yeah they
will figure out how to get into your
house if you leave your [ __ ] unlocked
they'll come in and rage your bridge
they're like we're friends with him he
won't mind
come in through a window or try to open
the doors they'll grab a lever try to
open doors they're like like a monkey
yeah you'd think well it's just paws no
it's like little hands they can open a
car door
yeah i've seen them open cars sit there
and put their hand on there i've seen
them pulling the treasure trying to open
the door i've seen him open front doors
like in people's houses yeah
so he's going oh he likes us he always
feeds us he's got food in there yeah and
they'll go in there and tear your house
up he's like bro i thought it was all
right we're friends throw food
everywhere [ __ ] on everything get in
your bed and sleep
three or four i'm sleeping in your bed
some goldilocks trying to just move in
with you
you know hey it's nice in here they
won't even run from you if they know you
they're like hey
we're here they're going to invite
themselves into your [ __ ] house
people got that in video i'm you know
just look it up on youtube they will
come right into your house and try to
move in with you yep
and then they try to boss you around
so no you don't want them in there
yeah you probably don't don't want to
befriend him yeah
uh danny rowling says she didn't finish
that uh ape canyon story yet there
wasn't that much to it i don't even know
if it was like a real thing that
happened but you know hey there's
dimitri
which dimitri you know which one dimitri
yeah okay what's up demetrius tom's
indian food will get all the bears
knocking on the door yeah that's true
yeah yeah
they might come in they might come in
like i said the closest we've had we had
one sitting on our uh driveway one time
yeah so uh so yeah so also there was a
case in 2018
where this was in montana
where
somebody
i don't know if they were like wearing
furs or whatever but there was somebody
out in the woods and then like a hunter
uh shot at them a bunch of times i don't
think they hurt them or killed them or
anything but they said that they thought
it was a bigfoot so it does happen so
like i said don't
don't put on like because like i said in
2012 there was a dude that wore a
ghillie suit and was like i'm going to
do an uh a youtube viral bigfoot fake
video and he got run over by a car yeah
dmitry's asked me what's up with the
peter steelwick
i get come on a show and [ __ ]
depending on whatever's going to happen
in in the show i change wigs up i change
wigs out at least what three wigs at
night
wigs and hats yeah so we're talking
about bigfoot this is my [ __ ] bigfoot
wig well i don't know it's like other
kinds of wigs well earlier elvis wig
i got a [ __ ] french artisan wig
i got [ __ ] uh
i got a michael caine wig
that's when i do do the hand i got
michael kane slash willy wonka yeah i
got a white dude wig which is a white i
got i got a founding father's wig
[ __ ] money
with a ponytail and everything yes
uh-huh i do them all
i should i'll put i'll put my sexual
tyrannosaur hat oh my god he's like
doubling up doubling up with a hat and
long hair oh my god now you kind of look
like the nude i don't know who they knew
just ted nugent okay
except well you have to understand
something you know where you're gonna
kill the deer get in the bucket and
eating eating like the indians it's it's
great yeah that's ted nugent was it i
thought that was btk no no that sounded
like your btk voice is it no oh well no
bt
now he's gonna stop trying to get me to
[ __ ] perform
what you're already doing it you're
already doing it okay
uh grab through hammer says don't wear
wookie costumes in the woods either yeah
that is not a good idea not a good idea
i mean i know you think it's like cute
and it's clever and everything honestly
even though the more we thought about it
because like i said we were gonna do a
whole skunk ape uh hoax kind of thing
but then holy crap what was that my hand
um we were gonna do that and then i was
just kind of like i don't know i don't
know if it'd be a good idea around here
you might like i said you might get shot
at
um but yeah so uh
so here was this thing
this happened so let's talk about like
some of the kind of more famous hoaxes
about this and then we can maybe kind of
wrap this up because we're almost at
three hours
and like this this lemon is like this
it's getting you it's so acid should i
add some water to it no it's fine all
right um so okay so like i said back in
the 1960s back in 1968
um
there was kind of this uh a traveling
exhibition that went around that had
this frozen body that was supposed to
supposed to be a sasquatch yeah this is
kind of famous now this sasquatch
was only about as tall as a person it
was only about 5 foot 11 so it's like it
wasn't super impressive
um so some of the story how these
stories kind of attached to it oh like
hunters killed it in
uh minnesota or
some like american soldiers killed it in
vietnam something like that and uh so
suppose it's supposedly like this
bigfoot type creature
so finally they got a primatologist in
there to look at it and figured out that
it was made of
latex
uh so i don't know if it's still there
but apparently it's at this uh museum
now called the museum of the weird in
austin texas that's where that is now
now here's uh
something about so there's this guy you
might have heard of this dude tom
biscardi have you heard of that guy he's
on coast to coast am all the time back
in the day uh no
so back in 2005 um he has a company
called searching for bigfoot inc
he's got that [ __ ] incorporated yeah it
is yeah i don't know if he has it
legally incorporated because he just
added her if he just added probably just
sound impressive because how much does
it cost to get incorporated nowadays i
kind of feel like it's sort of expensive
i don't know thank you david june good
show he says thank you
um
so he comes on coast to coast
um and he says this is the quote
98 sure that his group will be able to
capture a bigfoot which they had been
tracking
in the happy camp california area
so he comes on coast to coast and says
that
so then a month after that he comes back
on the show
and says
we captured a bigfoot
and we're right now setting up a
pay-per-view event so everybody can see
it because of course i remember when all
this [ __ ] happened yeah and then
so then he was on there so of course
like on coast to coast they're like oh
we'll come back and tell us about that
so a couple days later he's on there
again
when he comes back on there again a
couple days later never mind there's no
captive bigfoot um it was just this
random ass lady that told me that she
had one but she lied to me
and also everyone listening to this is
dumb
i miss coast guard or gullible for
believing him is basically so he
basically like blamed
blame himself well he blamed everyone
other than himself he blamed like the
audience oh you shouldn't have believed
me that was obviously [ __ ]
um
you know or
or
he kind of like waffled between y'all or
dumb for believing in the first place or
i was misled because i was told that
there was a captain bigfoot but oh i
guess she just made it up i still miss
coast to coast though that was a great
show man i still remember the elevator
to mars episode that's good
i kind of remember for some reason
that's the only one that i remembered
because i was listening to it going oh
my god seriously
art bill was the [ __ ]
i liked art bill he could he could
[ __ ] keep you going for hours and
he could keep you suspending your
disbelief for hours
about just some crazy [ __ ]
about a dude who's going to come on the
show who has a hole in the back of his
yard that's so deep that it goes down to
hell
sure yeah yeah he goes yes i do i have a
hole that goes all the way down
to to hell
and then well how do you know that it's
hell that is because i have recordings
and it's like what he's i've lowered a
microphone you know and he went in and
he sounds like he plays it it's probably
like
yeah yeah
everybody scream into the [ __ ]
microphone no but it sounds all distant
and echoey like it's like yeah i can do
this
you know way far away
and you know and he goes if you see look
at them they're all the souls screaming
and it's like all [ __ ] built that [ __ ]
up all how did he keep a straight face
though
how did he keep a straight face
knew he art bill [ __ ]
understood the audience
he never really committed
to crazy [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean
he was just presented presenting it
right and he just goes oh my god
that is
fascinating
yeah he's not saying you're not no no
he's not saying you're full of [ __ ] or
he wouldn't say you were full of [ __ ]
and he wouldn't say oh well this is
proof he would just talk about how
awesome it was the evidence elevator or
just whatever that's uh certainly
interesting
i don't think i've ever seen
heard anything like this
[Laughter]
we really must have you on again you
know just it is what was so great about
that
and what the thing is though is that
part of the thing that made that show
work is that it was when it was when i
was listening to it was pre-internet or
very early internet like web tv or
prodigy you know
so he didn't have youtube and [ __ ] so it
was hard to to research something there
wasn't enough information
on the internet back then
so you couldn't get on google earth and
look at where it was he was talking
about you couldn't check you know you
couldn't find you couldn't find
somebody's facebook page and look at the
dude so you didn't know who it was you
he was talking to right
so it was it was a more mysterious time
stuff was coming to light all the time
you know and then you could go on the
internet the primitive internet and and
try to look up some more information and
there'd be some more [ __ ] on there
that somebody put you know it's just
looking great you know it's a great time
yeah
it was a great time
well you could like use your imagination
well you could just like pretend it was
real i know sometime i knew it was
[ __ ] but i liked but it's a fun
story yeah i preferred to believe that
it was based on something that might be
it's the same appeal as um you know kind
of like those reddit ghost stories like
like no sleep and things like that
because it's like the whole thing about
that is that
you're supposed to present the stories
which some of which have paranormal some
of them are just like regular stalker
[ __ ] but like some of her paranormal and
you're just supposed to present it like
it really happened to you even if it's a
fictional story and everyone is just
kind of like
that it's almost kind of like you're
supposed to pretend it's true even if
you don't think it is like you're
supposed to treat it like it is but even
though some people know that it's not
you know what i mean it's just a sexy
beast
i know esther go ahead and take a
picture baby
see there's more
wait uh okay uh so okay so back in 2008
uh there was these two dudes named rick
dyer and matthew whitten and they put
this video up on youtube and they said
that they had found a dead bigfoot in
georgia which i guess would be a skunk
ape more than a big but like i said same
kind of thing
now tom biscardi the chuckle [ __ ] we
were talking about just earlier uh that
was on the coast coast am show saying
hey i got a bigfoot oh never mind no i
don't uh you guys are dummies um
he uh was contacted by the two guys he's
gonna like you know investigate the [ __ ]
right
so
the two dudes that made the youtube
video and so maybe we should see this is
why i think we should maybe make a like
a youtube video like faking this [ __ ]
all this was a long time ago i don't
think he'd get this kind of money
nowadays but these two dudes that made
this video
um
the company searching for bigfoot inc
um gave them fifty thousand dollars
for this [ __ ]
and this story actually ended up getting
like getting some main like media
traction you know what i mean like it
was on like you know fox and uh abc and
[ __ ] like that
so uh
so they're like okay well you have a
dead bigfoot like let's see it
so then uh and i i remember when this
happened too so like yeah here it is we
get like they send a freezer to the
searching for bigfoot uh you know
headquarters whatever you want to call
it this big freezer with like this
supposedly dead bigfoot in a block of
ice so they thawed out
uh and they discover
that and i remember this is on the news
too it's like somebody has a dead
bigfoot it's like that here it is it's
frozen and ice and they thought out it
was good um and it was uh obviously not
real it was a bunch of fake hair uh it
was a grossly made of no it was mostly
made of rubber i thought yeah yeah it
was like it was essentially like a
costume yeah uh yeah so
then like was you know some other like
absolutely when art bill made a big deal
about that i remember that one i
remember it being kind of a big deal
like hey but like there's a dead bigfoot
and here it is we have it's frozen and
then they're like oh nevermind it's just
a gorilla costume and a block of ice
what was funny about our bells you'd
have some [ __ ] like that on there but
then later on he'd have [ __ ] the dude
that did all the you know what's his
name graham hancock which i always liked
graham hancock some of his stuff seemed
plausible like the egyptian stuff
you ever seen any of that yeah about
where he's talking about where the where
the pyramids and certain structures are
placed to look a lot like constellations
in the sky
but they were talking about from another
time
i like the graham hancock stuff and the
weird anomalies with ancient maps
yeah that kind of stuff yeah i think
sure yeah
so it's kind of funny how in that era
everything was just kind of blending
together yeah now victor garcia says
yeah but you you still weren't doing
research if you're looking online dude
they have so much stuff online so you
can get audio books that are directly
just like the other ones and if you have
any experience doing research out of
libraries which we grew up doing that
too you'd find [ __ ] in the library
too
you can find classic [ __ ] books and
classic literature that is can all be
debunked now
like classics like edward gibbons
decline and fall roman empire yeah it's
got a lot right but it's also a lot
wrong in there that books from the 1700s
so you can do research in a library and
actually come up short
and not and come come away with bad
information if that's what you're
referring to
books don't mean [ __ ] a lot of those
books are [ __ ] wrong
a lot of them well it's just as easy to
write [ __ ] in a book and the book is
on the internet i mean it's easier
nowadays obviously but actually the
internet now is kind of like [ __ ]
fights itself so at least you know that
there's more than one story on the
internet
about a subject you know what i mean
there's a couple different viewpoints
you go back to an old book you only get
one man's viewpoint
and his information might have been bad
or out of date
yeah victor was saying about rick dyer
said they killed a bigfoot here in san
antonio that was actually the next uh
the absolute next thing i was gonna talk
about but yeah so the same dude rick
dyer in 2014
um who had done the you know hey we have
a dead bigfoot in ice whatever um yeah
he said that he had killed one in
september of 2012.
and he said that he had had all these
dna tests done on it he had like body
scans done on it [ __ ] like that
i shot it i did all these tests on it
i'm gonna show everybody
uh so he said that the body was in a
hidden location and he was gonna take it
on tour across the country in 2014. not
surprisingly uh this did not happen and
even though a bunch of people asked him
about the scans what were the results of
the dna test blah blah blah he was
really cagey about like kind of putting
that uh
you know information forward
um
he wouldn't tell like what lab had done
the dna tests
um
and
as far as it went like when the uh when
the tests actually did come out they
couldn't actually match them to any
animal that was known
uh so
he really did never end up making the
test results available to anyone
um he actually did take
this supposed body like on tour
he took it to houston
and then pretty much a month or two
later he came out on his facebook page
and said oh guess what as if anyone was
surprised this is also a hoax yeah uh he
actually had somebody make this prop
out of foam latex and camel hair
uh and yeah he got about sixty thousand
dollars from that little stunt so like i
said uh we're in the wrong line of work
yeah should have been hoax and [ __ ] that
wouldn't work nowadays though no i know
that was that well this was only this
was 2014. i mean that's a few years ago
yeah hugh goes in there asking what
about that hand that the the monks had
for up in the himalaya i know exactly
the hand you're talking about it's like
a little freeze dried yeah i remember
the noid hand i remember that uh i
remember that they wouldn't let people
take it anywhere i think for any kind of
testing they thought they thought it was
like a sacred item well didn't they do
like some hair tests on it and it was
just kind of like not yeah it's like i
remember saying that like i remember i
remember that some experts looked at it
and they said it was either a monkey
hand or a human hand i can't remember
what they said it was yeah i do remember
that they did some hair testing on it
and thought it wasn't like that weird no
this is something pretty common just
kind of a dried out hand i think it was
from a monkey but it might have been
from a human and it's been so long
yeah i do remember seeing a documentary
on that but it's been so long that i
don't really want to say like
definitively but i do remember on the
documentary they did say that it wasn't
it wasn't that it wasn't all that big
weird like it wasn't all that unusual it
just looked kind of freeze-dried you
know
it was kind of small from what i
remember yeah and i mean the thing about
it is that there have been a lot of
you know because there are some like
actual legit scientists that are
interested in this and it's like oh if
there is some unknown hominid or some
unknown ape we want to know what it is
so there have been a few that are
willing to kind of go and like test you
know hair samples that have been
submitted to them and things like that
but
as far as i'm aware um all of the
hair samples that have come forward
that are supposedly from a sasquatch
um
most of the ones that they have tested
like the large majority of them were
from bears uh some of them were from
kind of rare species of bears but most
of them were bears some were like other
animals like one of them was even from a
human uh one was from like you know just
just various other animals some were
from a cow or a horse or something like
that so it's like nothing that would
strike anyone as particularly
unusual you know what i'm saying like
none of them were really like
unidentified or weren't so strange as to
be like oh this is an unidentified
species type of thing
um you know so
i don't know like i said to me this kind
of seems like
a question of this is an animal
if it you know if it does exist i don't
any of that kind of like oh it's you
know extra dimensional or comes from
aliens or whatever that's obviously
[ __ ]
if this exists it's a real animal
and i'm not saying
because things like this did exist in
the past they do know that you know just
larger like eight or man-like things
that are more ape-like or whatever
that's not crazy
um whether they're still around though
that's a completely different question
it could just be that
we like you said we have some kind of
like weird like racial memory of them
because it was something that existed
you know in
in times past where you know the story
was passed through the generations you
know people that are seeing them
nowadays
it could be lots of things it could be
bears it could be gorillas it could be
like a what you know a gorilla escaped
from a zoo it could be lots of different
things
so
i don't know the fact until they come up
with and i'm not you know i'd be totally
happy if somebody came up and they
actually had
a sasquatch and it was a dead one and
they actually came and said look we
found one and they did all the tests on
it they're like yes this is absolutely a
gigantopithecus or whatever it is
um then i would totally accept it like i
said that it wouldn't be crazy to me did
not at all
i think a lot of it goes back to human
beings probably going back
a thousand years thousands of years
people in a tribal setting
traveling distances throughout the
country worried about being attacked by
other people
because that happened a lot
but then there's another fear that can
be
layered in what if these people that are
attacking you are bigger than you and
more savage than you
and then the worry even increases
they're bigger than you
more savage than you and they're more
primitive than you they're animal-like
they have hair on them
they're hair-like they don't even have
they don't have bows or arrows or knives
they just do it just pure like an animal
but if it's a man like that
but he's huge
that's something that the imagination
would i think
kind of invent well yeah because you're
extrapolating from something that's that
you already know that you already know
right and i feel like a lot of mythology
is kind of like that you're just kind of
taking i mean even going back to like
the very obvious example of like you
know greek mythology where they're
taking
humans but making them like super humans
like you know they're they're like us
but they're unlike yes you're a tribal
you've been attacked by
other tribal people in your travels to
the same
level as you
then later on you're attacked by some of
them that are
of you in technology you saw that they
had better clothes they had better bows
and arrows
well what if they're actually
far
less advanced than you and more like
animals that's also scary so i think
that's what they're doing i think that's
where it came from
because it's something logical
yeah
they don't need technology or tools
they're just like the other animals out
here they're just bigger and mean they
got hair all on them no clothes it
smells yeah
well that might have been i think that
was added later that wasn't mentioned
that wasn't mentioned in total because
everyone was smelly back then right
i think that's what it is it's the
imagination they're just imagining
opponents in different
directions of they're either above you
or below you
that's that's or they're the same as you
yeah you're worried about all three
things
and i think sasquatch and bigfoot is
worrying about being attacked by
something that is technologically
beneath you but physically superior
like a lion or a bear but it's a man
i think honestly yeah it is i honestly
think it'd be rad if like they found a
[ __ ] sasquatch
yeah something it's something like that
in my opinion it doesn't exist if it
does i don't i don't think it does
either but like i said if they did find
one i wouldn't be totally shocked
um
and it would be kind of cool but i
really don't think they're going to it's
more likely that what they call o-ring
pen deck exists
what was described sounds a lot more
plausible
and there have been some professionals
that have lived in that area western
professionals that know that are
zoologists and stuff biologists and they
believe that there is an orange pending
but it's kind of like a more
ground-based orangutan
yeah which like i said it's not crazy
there's just like another species that
is undiscovered which has happened
before but they put cameras out they
haven't seen any yeah
but i mean it might eventually
there was some expert who said he saw it
but it was moving fast on two legs yeah
and it looked like a little bipedal
orangutan running
it ran as good as a monkey yeah
um but he said it was kind of like
it had more of a humanoid gate to it
he thought that it might have been
something like that hobbit creature
which you know those didn't exist so
yeah it was on that island yeah i don't
know how far away that was from where
oring pendick is but yeah there were
like little little dwarf views yeah
that you know it did some people think
that those little
hobbits
things i forgot what they're called so
it was like a type of a homo erectus but
it was a real small one yeah well it's a
different species i just yeah [ __ ] man
i've totally they think it may have had
a human style intelligence just because
it was small didn't mean that it was a
monkey-like intelligence it was probably
pretty humanoid yeah because all animals
had gotten smaller on that island
even the that tends to happen on islands
in general the elephants were about the
size of a pony if i remember correctly
and they had a lot of little miniature
a lot of little miniature elephants
because that's what it took to survive
there without eating up all the food
yeah i mean because like i said over
time uh you know species adapt to their
environments if you live in a sort of
island environment yeah
where resources are you know not as
plentiful yeah then
you know they're gonna get smaller if i
remember correctly the elephants were
about the size of a pony and it was kind
of a new species of elephant and the
humans were proportionately small they
would but relative to the elephant they
were about the same
as as a proportion yeah sure which is
you know two and a half something feet
tall humans against a
a pony size elephant yeah which like i
said yeah everything shrunk down kind of
uniformly evidently a lot of the stuff
did does anybody remember i remember a
few years ago and i wish i could
remember what it was called but there
was like a whole series of
little books they weren't children's
books they were for adults but they were
kind of like they looked like they were
drawn the whole the conceit behind them
was that they were
a sasquatch
autobiography that he had written
himself and he had kind of like drawn it
with like crayons and what the [ __ ] was
it called i was i there was like two or
three of them there might be more of
them now but i just remember seeing them
a few years ago and one of my friends
had them and they were like super super
funny but they were kind of like what
were they called
me bigfoot
something like i think the first one was
called me bigfoot and it was kind of um
and it was just him talking about his
life but he was talking like the way
that a bigfoot would be talking and like
i said it looked like he had drawn it
with crayons like little pictures of
like little words and stuff and it was
just like it was super super cute if
anybody like knows what i'm talking
about it's it's been like a few years
and i know that there was more than one
i can't remember if the first one was
called i think it was called me bigfoot
but
oh my god so we're signing out
[Laughter]
no you now you've just put a new wig on
now we have no i'm not like no no no
so you have to like say something she's
[ __ ] you
there you go
all right so like what time is it okay
it's time to go it's quarter past nine
all right yeah so [ __ ] man now i gotta
[ __ ] get ready and go out won't take
long
it won't take long for you
your makeup's not already
i know but it looks kind of crappy
because it's been on all just put a blue
wig on you're good to go put your
clothes on and go it only takes a few
minutes
all right the longer it takes to close
down the less time we have
all right fine he's like trying to rush
me all right so hopefully you guys
should i gotta do got the food cooking
too oh that's right uh hopefully you
guys enjoyed the show about bigfoot i
had a good time we didn't get two days i
mostly stayed on we mostly stayed on
topic which is always amazing uh but
yeah so we'll be back on sunday probably
be talking about cocaine cowboys because
that's a thing that we just watched we
watched that whole series yeah you can
watch it uh on netflix on netflix yeah
it's actually really good it's really
it's a good series what is it it's only
it's only like four episodes six seven
seven six six episodes okay
yeah but it's i thought it was just four
but okay i can't remember um but yeah
it's really good so we'll be back on
sunday afternoon you guys have a good
weekend up until then and we will talk
to you guys later
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you